Hey everybody. So one of my most fond memories is playing this game, this really esoteric game called Essex, which I think is named after a place in the UK. But it was this game where it was like Zork, if you are familiar with that, but it was one of these text-based story games where you would type, you know, go north, go west. And the thing that amazed me, I mean, I was maybe seven or eight years old. The thing that amazed me was that I could, I felt like I could just say anything to these computer players and that they would respond with really interesting things. And it ran on a single floppy disk. And so, you know, honestly, to this day,
大家好。所以，我最美好的回忆之一就是玩这个游戏，一个非常冷门的游戏，叫做“埃塞克斯”（Essex），我想它是以英国的一个地方命名的。但这个游戏有点像《佐克》（Zork），如果你熟悉的话，它是那种基于文本的故事游戏，你会在其中输入，你知道的，向北走，向西走。让我惊奇的是，我的意思是，我当时可能只有七八岁。让我惊奇的是，我觉得我可以对这些电脑玩家说任何话，而它们会用非常有趣的事情来回应。而且它在一张软盘上运行。所以，老实说，直到今天，
it kind of blows my mind. But as a child, it just completely blew my mind. I mean, I was wondering if there was a real person somehow involved like, you know, in real time. And I've always been really interested in conversational AI. And I feel like we're all just exceptionally lucky to have Joe Bradley here, who is the chief scientist at LivePerson, who is an expert in this field and really going to talk
这还是让我有点震撼。但作为一个孩子，它完全震撼了我。我的意思是，我在想是否真的有人通过某种方式参与其中，比如，你知道的，实时地。我一直对对话式人工智能非常感兴趣。我觉得我们能邀请到 LivePerson 的首席科学家乔·布拉德利（Joe Bradley）来到这里，我们真是极其幸运，他是这个领域的专家，真的要跟我们
to us about how conversational AI kind of works, a bit of the history behind it and how kind of LivePerson and other folks do it today. So thanks so much for coming on the show, Joe. Hey, thanks for having me. I'm really excited to be here and even more excited about the fact that you just brought up zork for me that was the one it wasn't the you know the essex or that that i i didn't know about but but yeah i spent hours doing that as a kid and it's funny too i have children myself now and i see them you know just just last week i went downstairs and they're not playing zork right right? But they're playing the equivalent on the Amazon device on the Alexa. Somebody's coded up a little like exploration game and now they're talking to that. But it's essentially the same interface, just with the voice instead of text.
聊聊对话式人工智能是怎么运作的，它背后的历史，以及 LivePerson 和其他人今天是怎么做的。非常感谢你能来节目，乔。嘿，谢谢邀请我。我真的很高兴来到这里，更高兴的是你刚才提到了《佐克》，那是我的最爱，不是那个，你知道的，埃塞克斯，或者我不知道的那个，但是，是的，我小时候花了好几个小时玩那个。而且很有趣的是，我自己现在也有了孩子，我看到他们，就在上周，我下楼去，他们玩的不是《佐克》，对吧？但他们在 Amazon 设备 Alexa 上玩等效的东西。有人编写了一个类似的小型探索游戏，现在他们在和那个对话。但本质上是相同的界面，只是用语音代替了文字。
And it's still fun for them, which I think is like really interesting, even in this age of like, hey, does everything have to be these like cool looking graphics? And, you know, what's the UX got to be like, there's still something powerful about just talking to a machine, like you can like, like you want to, and in a way that's easy in a way that's natural for you. And then having the thing respond and tell you a story, right? That's, that's cool still. Yeah, I think that, you know, when it's abstract like that, you kind of, you know, your mind fills in those gaps and fills them in a way that's like really interesting and pleasing to you. Right. And so that's kind of the, I think, who's the Scott McCloud, I want to say, if I'm getting that right. But he wrote a book about understanding comics. And he explains that the reason why comics are, originally they're meant to be written really quickly, but another reason why comics work so well as a medium
对他们来说这仍然很有趣，我认为这真的很酷，即使在这个“嘿，一切都必须是这些酷炫图形吗？”的时代。而且，你知道，用户体验必须是什么样的，仅仅和机器对话仍然有一些强大之处，就像你可以像你想的那样去对话，以一种简单、对你来说自然的方式。然后让那个东西回应并给你讲一个故事，对吧？那是，那依然很酷。是的，我认为，当它是如此抽象时，你会，你知道的，你的大脑会填补那些空白，并以一种对你来说真正有趣和愉悦的方式去填补它们。没错。所以这就是，我认为，斯科特·麦克劳德（Scott McCloud）是谁，我想这么说，如果我没记错的话。但他写了一本关于理解漫画的书。他解释说，漫画最初之所以要被快速创作，漫画之所以能成为如此出色的媒介的另一个原因
is that they're so abstract that when you watch, for example, Dilbert, you kind of put yourself into Dilbert versus if Dilbert was photorealistic, you wouldn't really be able to do that as easily. And so yeah, games like Zorkork and Essex, they do that. Your mind fills in all those gaps. Yeah, they hit this spot for us that's like,
是它们非常抽象，当你观看时，比如呆伯特（Dilbert），你会把自己代入呆伯特，而如果呆伯特是写实的，你就不会那么容易做到这一点。所以，是的，《佐克》和《埃塞克斯》这样的游戏就是这样。你的大脑填补了所有这些空白。是的，它们击中了我们的一个点，就像，
if you think about how evolved we are to have conversation, right? And how important conversation is to us as human beings, right? It's the fundamental way in which we created efficiency, resources, wealth, right? All the things that we have today are founded on the abstractions that make conversations possible, right? Language itself. And then the ability to have those
如果你想想我们进化到能够进行对话的程度，对吧？以及对话对我们人类有多么重要，对吧？这是我们创造效率、资源、财富的根本方式，对吧？我们今天拥有的一切，都建立在使对话成为可能的抽象概念之上，对吧？语言本身。然后是拥有这些对话的能力，
in a two-way or multi-way dialogue so that you can build more than just what's inside your own mind, right? So I think in some ways it's like surprising when I look at my kids playing Zork on So I think in some ways, it's like surprising when I look at my kids playing Zork on that device. And in other ways, it's like, oh, no, wait, we're evolved to do this. Like, this is what we want. We want to build stories. And now it's just interesting. It's kind of interesting that last 30, 40 years, we've begun to be able to do that
通过双向或多向对话，这样你就可以构建不仅仅是你自己内心深处的东西，对吧？所以我认为在某些方面，当我看到我的孩子们在玩《佐克》时，这让我感到惊讶。而在另一些方面，这就像，哦，不，等等，我们就是进化来做这件事的。就像，这就是我们想要的。我们想要构建故事。现在这很有趣。过去三四十年，我们开始能够做到这一点，
with inanimate objects, right? And that like, we sort of know, and we sort of don't care, and it's sort of still fun. Yeah, it's amazing. So I want to dive into, I'd love to know how these things, how Zork works and then also fast forwarding the future. But before we get into the tech side of it, you know, what is kind of your background and what led you to building conversational AI at LifePerson? What's that story like? Yeah, it's a little, I don't want to say topsy-turvy because it's not a bad story in my mind, but it's definitely a little all over the place.
与无生命的对象，对吧？而且就像，我们某种程度上知道，某种程度上不在乎，而且它某种程度上仍然很有趣。是的，这太神奇了。所以我想要深入探讨，我很想知道这些东西，佐克是如何运作的，然后也展望未来。但在我们进入技术层面之前，你知道，你的背景是什么，是什么促使你在 LifePerson 构建对话式人工智能？那是个怎样的故事？是的，有点，我不想说它是颠三倒四的，因为它在我看来不是一个糟糕的故事，但它绝对有点杂乱无章。
So if you go back far enough, you start getting to an interest in opera singing and a major in English literature and a whole bunch of stuff that doesn't fit very well with where I am today, at least not in most people's minds. So for me, I tend to have moments of five-year moments in my life where I get really, really passionate about something, and those end up being a stepping stone to kind of somewhere else. And so when I was, you know, at an undergraduate school and, and starting, you know, working as a classroom teacher in San Francisco, I got reminded about how, you know, I was teaching math and science to, to seventh graders, which is by the way, the hardest job
所以如果你追溯得足够远，你就会开始对歌剧演唱产生兴趣，主修英国文学，还有一大堆和我的现状不太相符的东西，至少在大多数人看来是这样。对我来说，我的人生中往往会有五年的时间，我对某事产生非常非常大的热情，而这些热情最终成为了通往其他地方的跳板。所以当我在，你知道的，一所大学里，并且开始，你知道的，在旧金山担任课堂老师时，我想起了，你知道的，我是如何教七年级学生数学和科学的，顺便说一句，这是我
I've ever done by a factor of 10. It sounds difficult. I remember middle school as being one of the hardest points. I've only ever been in one fist fight in my entire life other than martial arts, which doesn't count. And it was in middle school because somebody, oh, I was playing basketball and I blocked somebody because I'm a very tall, but I'm not particularly athletic, but I do have the height. And I blocked someone and he was upset. And actually, I wouldn't really call it a fist fight. He just punched me in the face and I was really upset about that. But yeah, but I think middle school is extremely challenging age. And, you know, Patrick and I also have kids. And so that's that's an age I'm not really looking forward to, but we'll have to get through it.
做过最难的工作，难度系数乘以十。听起来很难。我记得初中是我经历过最艰难的时期之一。除了武术不算，我一生中只打过一次架。那是在初中，因为有人，哦，我在打篮球，我盖了一个人的帽，因为我很高，但我不是很擅长运动，但我确实有身高优势。我盖了一个人，他不高兴。实际上，我真的不称之为打架。他只是打了我的脸，我对此感到非常沮丧。但是，是的，但我认为初中是一个极具挑战性的年龄。而且，你知道的，帕特里克和我也有孩子。所以那是我并不是真的很期待的年龄，但我们必须度过它。
Yeah, I mean, a couple like I will will not forget the day one of my students, she was this probably about six foot tall, 12 year old girl looked at me and she said, I was like, just getting started. And I was like, you know, like I said, it was this undergrad English, English major who was like, I want to go be helpful. I want to go do something meaningful in a, you know, in, in a city. And I just moved to San Francisco. So I got this job teaching and I was a couple months in, I wasn't, I was not good at it yet. I hadn't figured it out. And she looks up at me
是的，我是说，有一次，我不会忘记那一天，我的一个学生，她是一个大概六英尺高、12 岁的女孩看着我，她说，我当时就像是，刚刚开始。而我当时就像是，你知道的，就像我说的，我是一个本科英语专业的学生，想要去帮忙。我想在一个城市里做一些有意义的事情。我刚刚搬到旧金山。所以我找到了这份教书的工作，才几个月，我还不擅长。我还没摸透门道。她抬起头看着我
and she says, Hey, Mr. Bradley, this class is just like WWF Smackdown. And I like, I mean, I hung my head that day. Like it was, it was not like I, cause she was right. Right. I was like, wow, this is this is not good. And I mean, thankfully, the institution of public school in San Francisco was very helpful. They brought me this mentor teacher who who had all this knowledge about how to work with kids. It's really just like like simple things that you'd never think of. Right. Like don't talk about what one kid isn't doing well, stand next to them and talk to the kid who's doing it right and praise them. And then the other kid's going to suddenly look up and want to do the right thing. You know, all these sort of tricks of the trade that were just like changing, life changing for me.
然后她说：“嘿，布拉德利先生，这个班就像世界摔跤娱乐（WWF）的疯狂大赛（SmackDown）。”我当时就像，我的天啊，我那天垂头丧气。就像是，这可不是闹着玩的，因为她是正确的。对吧？我当时想，哇，这可真不妙。我的意思是，谢亏了旧金山的公立学校体制，它非常有帮助。他们给我请来了一位导师，她拥有关于如何与孩子相处的所有知识。真的就像是一些你想不到的简单事情。对吧？不要去谈论哪个孩子什么地方做得不好，站在他们旁边，去表扬那个做对了的孩子。然后另一个孩子就会突然抬起头来，想要做正确的事情。你知道，所有这些行当的窍门对我来说都是改变人生、彻底改变的。
But anyway, yeah. So to get back to your question, you know, I sort of rediscovered a love I had for math. I studied a bit in college and I was I was doing teacher training on, you know, negative adding negative numbers or something like that. How do you how do you teach a 12-year-old how to do that? And what are good visualizations and all these things? And it just brought back to me like, oh, man, I had so many questions State system, which I think deserves a plug because I feel extremely fortunate to have been able to go get an advanced degree in mathematics and pay something at the time like 800 bucks a semester to do it. Oh my gosh, amazing.
但不管怎样，是的。所以回到你的问题，你知道，我重新发现了对数学的热爱，我在大学里学过一点，我当时在做教师培训，关于，你知道的，负数相加或者类似的事情。你如何教一个 12 岁的孩子做这个？什么是好的可视化以及所有这些事情？这让我回想起，哦，天哪，我有这么多的问题，州立系统，我认为它值得一个广告，因为我觉得非常幸运，能够去攻读数学的高级学位，当时每学期只需要付大约 800 美元。哦，天哪，太棒了。
It's more now. I know it's more now, but I think it's still a pretty good deal. And back then, that's life-changing stuff, right? Like these are cultural institutions that we have built for ourselves that's that's life-changing stuff right like these are cultural institutions or you know that we have built for ourselves that that affect people's progress in life dramatically and so that was a special i think that's a special institution for me that was a special time uh you know and that kind of led into physics right like i was doing the math i was like well i want to i want to do something with this math as fun as the abstraction is i've always kind of been attracted to abstraction i wanted i wanted to be good for something. So I ended up going up to University
现在更多了。我知道现在更多了，但我认为这仍然是一笔不错的交易。在那个时候，那是改变人生的大事，对吧？就像这些是我们为自己建立的文化机构，那是改变人生的大事，对吧？就像这些是文化机构，或者你知道的，我们为自己建立的文化机构，它们极大地影响了人们在生活中的进步。所以这是一个特殊的，我认为对我来说是一个特殊的机构，那是一个特殊的时期，呃，这有点引导我走向物理学，对吧？就像我在做数学，我当时想，嗯，我想，我想用这个数学做点什么，尽管抽象很有趣，但我一直有点被抽象所吸引，我希望，我希望它能发挥作用。所以我最终去了华盛顿大学，
of Washington, moving up to Seattle and working on a PhD in physics. And that kind of led me to, you know, a lot, obviously more applied mathematics, obviously beginning to work in statistics much more deeply because I ended up doing a bunch of experimental work. And, you know, in addition to turning bolts and building instruments and firing x-rays and lasers and stuff, like you've got to go do the data analysis. And we started to think that there were some, you know, more advanced statistical analyses that would help us understand convolutions of data and all these things that, so that started to filter in. And as I became a full-time scientist, I just found a lot more passion for that when I was working at the National Labs.
搬到了西雅图，并攻读物理学博士学位。这在很大程度上引导我走向了，你知道的，显然更多应用数学，显然开始更深入地研究统计学，因为我最终做了很多实验工作。而且，你知道的，除了拧螺栓、建造仪器、发射 X 射线和激光之类的东西之外，你还得做数据分析。我们开始认为有一些，你知道的，更高级的统计分析可以帮助我们理解数据的卷积以及所有这些事情，所以这开始渗透进来。当我成为一名全职科学家时，我在国家实验室工作时，我发现对此有了更多热情。
And it was one sort of component of a larger decision that led me to change tracks and end up kind of in the industry I'm in today. And that was kind of by way of Amazon, right? So I sent all these resumes out because I was interested in, I'm getting into machine learning. It's a live field. It's new. I think I have been reading the papers. I've been like, this is a fun time, as opposed to physics, which is like hundreds of years old and everything's super sub-disciplined and very,
这是导致我改变轨道并最终进入我今天所在的行业的更大决定的一个组成部分。这有点是通过亚马逊的方式，对吧？所以我寄出了所有这些简历，因为我对机器学习很感兴趣。这是一个活跃的领域。它是新鲜的。我想我一直在读论文。我一直在想，这是一个有趣的时代，而不是像物理学那样有几百年历史，所有东西都超级细分，非常、非常狭隘，非常、非常紧凑。要接近任何最先进的技术都需要很长时间。我想，机器学习，嗯，这不同，对吧？这是新鲜的。这是活跃的。你可以学会它，不是很快。这不容易。我不是那个意思，但你可以更有效地到达该领域的前沿。而且我认为机器学习社区分享知识的方式有很多，他们正在开创这种学术研究和共享代码以及所有这些物理学中没有真正发生的事情，现在开始这样做了，是的，我认为，我认为你在经济学上也看到了同样的事情。所以我一直对经济学真的很感兴趣，嗯，你所看到的机器学习开始，因为归根结底，经济学，尤其是微观
very narrow and very, very tight. And it takes a long time to approach anything state-of-the-art. I was like, machine learning, well, this is different, right? This is new. This is live. You can learn it, not quickly. It's not easy. I don't mean to say that, but you can get to the front of the discipline much more effectively. And I think there's just a lot of ways in which knowledge is shared in the ML community and they're pioneering this academic research and shared code and all these things that wasn't really happening in physics that that's starting to now yeah i think i think you're seeing the same thing with economics so i've always been really interested in economics and um and what you're seeing is ml start because ultimately economics is is especially micro
经济学，归根结底是关于人和他们的行为方式的。所以你需要，它本质上是统计学的，因为我们不会拥有一个人类大脑处理器。所以我们将对其进行估计。所以，是的，你看到机器学习在该领域取得了巨大的进步。而且我认为在某个时候，机器学习将会普及并成为所有这些领域的一部分。而且正如我们现在所知，机器学习将变得更像是一个核心，你知道的，我们如何把学习做得很好？但我认为我们会到达这样一个点，也许甚至连对话式人工智能都不会是机器学习。它可能是语音理解或类似东西的一部分。是的，我认为这是对的。我的意思是，如果你真的退后一步，
economics is ultimately about people and the way they behave. And so you need to, it's statistical by nature because we're not going to have a human brain processor. So we're going to be estimating that. And so, yeah, you're seeing ML make a ton of strides in that field. And I think at some point ML will diffuse and just be a part of all of these fields. And ML, as we know it now, will become more of like a core, you know, how do we make the learning really well? But I think we'll get to the point where maybe even conversational AI won't even be ML. It might be part of like a speech understanding or something like that. Yeah, I think that's right. I mean, I think if you really back up
去思考什么是机器学习，甚至如果你在神经网络的背景下去思考它，它们到底在做什么？它们正在处理这些性质上不同的问题，因为它们具有高度的维度性，并且在描述它们的变量之间存在着奇怪的相关性集合。然后它们试图在这些变量中找到
and think about what machine learning is, and even if you think about that in the context of the neural nets, what are they really doing? They're taking these qualitatively different kind of problems because they have such a high degree of dimensionality and such a weird set of correlations across the variables that describe them. And then they're trying to find these
真正、真正有用的局部潜在极小值。这些真正、真正有用的解决方案，无论它们是不是，你知道的，完美的或全局的，你知道的，我知道有一整支机器学习分支专门致力于寻找，你知道的，凸优化问题以及所有这些东西，对吧？但是我认为该领域的发展方式
really, really useful local potential minimum in them. These really, really useful like solutions, whether or not they're, you know, the perfect or the global, you know, and I know there's a whole branch of ML that's devoted to finding, you know, convex problems and all that stuff, right? Like, but I think the way the field's evolving
是我们意识到，真实问题在维度上过于复杂，无法以那些确切的方式解决，甚至无法近似朝向那些全局解决方案。而我们都可以接受某种程度上的这些局部解决方案，但这将像任何具有近似真实问题的东西的领域一样，大多数好的领域都会受益于这种基本方法。我认为，我的意思是，显然这创造了新的问题，比如，嗯，你怎么知道你的答案是否足够好，什么叫足够好，但对于真实问题，就像这些是，这些是你必须应对的问题。
is we realize that like real problems are like way too dimensionally complex to solve in those exact ways or to even approximate towards those global solutions. And we're all just okay with sort of these local solutions, but that's going to like, like any field that has anything approximating a real problem. And most good fields do it's going to benefit from, from that basic approach. I think, I mean, obviously creates new problems of like, well, how do you know if your answer is good enough and what is good enough mean, but for real problems, like those are,, those are questions you just have to cope with.
是的。所以你没有计算机科学学位，对吗？不，不。我是一个研究型的自学程序员，一开始是这样的。当我为亚马逊工作时，我肯定上了一门速成课，了解这把我变成了一个多么糟糕的程序员。所以，是的，让我们稍微倒退一点。你是怎么在亚马逊面试的？因为这是我们经常被问到的问题。有人说，我有物理背景，或者我有经济学背景，或者我有化学工程背景。而且我想去亚马逊面试。
Yeah. So you don't have a CS degree, correct? No, no. I'm a research self-taught programmer at start anyway. And I got a little bit of a crash course about how bad a programmer that made me when I worked at Amazon, for sure. So yeah, let's go back a tiny bit. How did you interview at Amazon? Because this is something we get asked constantly. Someone says, I have a background in physics, or I have a background in economics, or I have a background in chemical engineering. And I want to interview at Amazon.
你是如何培养出那种能够做到这一点的正确心态的？是的。所以，这是一个有点运气的例子，但我也对我是如何做到的有意的。所以我不能声称这总是奏效，但我认为这是一个相对聪明的策略。所以我稍微解释一下。所以，正如我所说，我寄出了一堆简历，却几乎没有得到回复，对吧？就像，这是谁？
How did you get that right mindset to be able to do that? Yeah. So, so it was a case of like, there's a little bit of luck in there, but I also was intentional about how I did it. So I can't claim this will always work, but I think it was a relatively smart strategy. So I'll explain it a little bit. So I did, as I said, I sent out a bunch of resumes and heard very little back, right? It's like, who's this?
你知道，基本上我认为人们看到那简历会想，这个国家实验室搞 X 射线实验的是谁，把这东西从我桌上拿开，对于大多数理智的人来说，这是一个挺容易做出的反应。或者可悲的是它甚至是一个人工智能。所以一个人甚至没有机会看到潜力，对吧？有可能。我的意思是，我们绝对，LivePerson 的招聘人员，对吧？他们仍然看很多简历，但我认为有搜索查询。你知道的，你得对如何设置简历保持聪明。你想在上面放正确的搜索词，所有这些东西。就像你得通过，你得让人类看它。那是真的。是的。然后我
You know, basically I think people would see that resume and be like, who's this national lab business is like doing x-ray experiments, get this thing off my desk is like, was kind of an easy response for most sane humans to have. Or sadly it's even an AI. So a person didn't even have an opportunity to see the potential, right? Could be. I mean, we definitely, our recruiters at LivePerson, right? They look at a lot of resumes still, but I think there's search queries. You know, you got to be smart about how you set up your resume. You want to have the right search terms on it, all this stuff. Like you got to get past, you got to get a human looking at it. That's true. Yep. And then what I
做的，即使当时没有人要求或者不常见，现在可能更少见了，我写了我认为是一封深思熟虑的求职信，解释了我到底在干什么，以及为什么我认为这说得通。所以我试图分解我的经验。特别是，我花了一段时间精心打造了一段话，关于我如何在国家实验室的背景下做这些实验，我们进去，我们有有限的 X 射线束时间，我们坐下来，我们有，你知道的，24 小时来做实验。我们必须对如何规划它进行深思熟虑。我们必须非常擅长解决问题。我们必须，你知道的，我们必须在这个非常紧凑、受限制的环境中真正交付成果，否则我们将无法成功。我的推销就像是，来看看我交付了什么。这就是产出，这些出版物的产出，这个领域的进步，对吧？所以我试图做到，我不想把那变成四页的独白。
did is I wrote, even though it wasn't asked for or common at the time, and it's probably less so now, I wrote what I thought was a thoughtful cover letter explaining what the heck I was doing there and why the heck I thought this made sense. And so I tried to break down my experience. In particular, I spent, you know, like a while crafting this paragraph about how I had been doing these experiments in a national lab context where we'd go in and we'd have limited x-ray beam time and we'd sit down and we'd have, you know, 24 hours to conduct the experiment. And we had to be very thoughtful about how we planned it. We had to be very good at troubleshooting problems. We had to, you know, we had to really deliver in this very tight, constrained environment or we were not going to be successful. And my pitch was like, here's, look at what I've delivered. Here's the output, the output of these publications, this advance in this field, right? So I tried to get, I didn't want to make that like a four page monologue.
那就像不得不把它削减到，你知道的，四到五句好句子。有一个招聘人员。我曾经认识她。我现在忘了她的名字了，因为已经过去好一会儿了。通话结束后我可能会想起来。但有这么一位女性，她是招聘人员，看到了它并读了它，并且觉得，她当时就像是，我认为这行得通，对吧？我想我们应该和这家伙谈谈。我确实和她谈过了。正如我所说，我跟她谈过，你知道的，在我加入亚马逊之后，我和她有过几次对话。她把这个转述给我，说阅读其中的一些文本是她做决定的一个重要部分。当然，这不是唯一的事情。但我认为这样做是聪明的。我认为，
Right. That was like had to whittle that down to, you know, to four or five good sentences. And there was some recruiter. I knew her at one point. I've forgotten her name now because it's been quite a while. It'll probably come to me after the after the call. But there was this woman who who was a recruiter who saw it and read it and just thought like she was just like, I think this could work, right? I think we should talk to this guy. And I did talk to her. As I said, I talked to her, you know, later after I joined Amazon, I had a couple of conversations with her. And she kind of relayed this to me that reading some of that text was an important part in her decision making. It wasn't the only thing, of course. But I think that's smart to do. I think,
你知道的，很明显，你必须通过人工智能或查询，所有这些东西。但接着你应该记住，有一个，如果你还记得，另一端有一个人类，他们需要我说得通。如果我不是来自他们所看到和期望的背景，他们需要我解释为什么我的经验是合适的，以及这个故事应该如何组合在一起。我们归根结底都是叙事机器，所以他们需要我给他们那个叙事，并在你的简历或求职信中花时间和空间，无论你用什么方式，确保那个故事被讲述，并确保那个故事清晰，但也要确保它超级简洁紧凑。我怎么强调这一点都不为过。如果你写得好，这也说明了一些问题。而且你没有那么多的注意力。你应该想象你只有 30 秒的注意力，
you know, obviously, you got to get past the sort of AI or the querying, all that stuff. But then you should remember, there's a, if you remember, there's a human on the other end of this and they need me to make sense. If I'm not coming from what they see and what they expect, they need me to make sense of why my experience fits and how that story should go together. We're all narrative machines in the end, so they need me to give them that narrative and take the time and the space in your resume or in a cover letter, however you do it, to make sure that story is told and make sure that story is clear, but also make sure it's like super concise and tight. Like I can't make that point strongly enough. If you write well, that also says something. And you don't have a lot of attention. You should imagine you've got 30 seconds of attention
如果运气好的话。我怎么能这么快就把那个故事讲完呢？是的，绝对的。所以当你去亚马逊时，你第一天就在做对话式人工智能，还是那是你后来过渡到的团队？我最终在亚马逊和后来的耐克做了很多
if you're lucky. How do I tell that story that quick? Yeah, absolutely. And so when you went to Amazon, were you working on conversational AI on day one, or is that something that you, a team that you transitioned to later? So I ended up doing a number
自然语言应用。其中很多都与他们在产品方面的兴趣、产品对他们有什么用处、诸如此类的事情、他们的网站体验是什么样的、对文本的大量分析有关。我开始与我们在 LivePerson 的一些专家一起构建对话式人工智能。我真正第一次涉足对话式人工智能是在 LivePerson。那是我开始构建的地方。我们引进了很多人。所以我认为自己更多是一个通才。我的背景更多是统计学、机器学习等等。我
of natural language applications at Amazon and at Nike subsequently. A lot of it related to what kinds of interests they have in products, what's useful to them about products, things like that, what their website experience was like, a lot of analysis of text. And I started building conversational AI with some of the experts we have at LivePerson. My real first foray into conversational AI was with LivePerson. That's where I began to build. And we've brought on a lot of people. So I consider myself a little bit more of a generalist. My background's more statistics, machine learning, et cetera. I
显然在过去三四年在 LP 工作期间学到了很多关于对话式人工智能的知识。但我们当然也有把整个职业生涯都花在这上面的人。明白了。好的。所以如果你能为我们在这里铺平道路。所以有自然语言处理，我认为，请在这里纠正我，这是一个伞形术语，涵盖了，比方说，翻译，也许还有嵌入或语义理解，不，不，我，你知道的，我对这个领域的语义描述更准确。但是，是的，总的来说，自然语言处理就像一个大盒子。那个盒子里面装的是处理自然语言的科学，对吧？字面意思。对话式人工智能是自然语言处理的一种。它是一种非常具体的，显然非常重要的，我们认为是这样的。但是，是的，是的，我认为这很公平。
obviously have learned a lot about conversational AI in the last three, four years working at LP. But we, of course, have people that have spent their whole careers on it as well. Got it. Okay. So if you could kind of lay the land for us here. So there's natural language processing, which I think, and please correct me here, is an umbrella that covers, let's say, translation, maybe embeddings or semantic understandings, no, no, my under, you know, my semantic description of this field is more accurate. But yeah, I mean, by and large, NLP is like a big box. And inside that box goes like the science of processing natural language, right? Like kind of quite literally. And conversational AI is a kind of processing of natural language. It's a very specific one, obviously a very important one, we think. But yeah, yeah, I think that's fair.
你在对话式人工智能内部和/或自然语言处理内部，你知道的，还有自然语言理解这个子领域。对吧？这，再次强调，对对话式人工智能非常重要。这有点像，你知道的，又是那种名副其实的领域。所以它是试图，你知道的，使用算法来创造的科学，你知道的，我们所说的理解本质上是什么意思，即对我们使用的自然语言的单词进行结构化的形式或结构化的解释，你知道的，从这种非结构化的文本中，你知道的，从那个格式出发，并，并且开始对这些自然语言话语进行分类，你知道的，并用诸如
You also have inside of conversational AI and or inside of natural language processing, you know, you have the subfield of natural language understanding. Right. Which is which is, again, very important to conversational AI. And that's sort of this, you know, again, it's another one of these ones that like is what it says it is. Right. So it is the science of trying to, you know, use algorithms to create, you know, what do we mean by understanding essentially a structured form of or a structured interpretation of words, of natural language that we use, you know, go from this like unstructured text, you know, go from that format and, and sort of begin to categorize and, you know, and adorn these natural language utterances with, with like things that are
对我们在抽象中具有意义的东西来修饰它们。是的，这说得通。然后在另一个方向，你谈论的是自然语言生成，在那里你说，我有这个结构，这个包含我知道某人需要的信息的 JSON。电影在这个时间开始，或者这是你的披萨订单准备好的时候，它必须被变成人们会觉得感觉自然的文本。没错。是的。你有那个，你知道的，元数据的语义盒子，无论你是怎么得到它的，无论那个语义是从哪里产生的，某个系统做了一些处理，并且，并且说，机器，这是我想要你说的语义或意思。
meaningful to us in the abstract. Yeah, that makes sense. And then in the other direction, then you're talking about natural language generation, where you say, I have this structure, this JSON, which has this information that I know somebody needs. The movie starts at this time, or this is when your pizza order is ready, and it has to get turned into text that people would, it would feel natural to them. That's right. Yeah. You've got that, you know, the sort of semantic box of metadata, however you get it, you know, wherever that arose from some system did some processing and, and said like, here's, here's the semantics or the meaning of what I want you to say machine.
然后，NLG 部分，输入是那个，输出是口语或书面语言或无论它是什么。中间的另一个部分，人们可以以不同的方式对其进行切片和组合，并且它仍然是一个非常开放的研究问题，实际上围绕着所有的对话管理。所以你有进来的文本或进来的文字。假设它只是书面文本，因为这样你就可以随时在管道的另一端对语音和声音方面进行建模。所以你有进来的文本。
And then the, the NLG post portion, like input is that, output is spoken language or written language or whatever it is. The other piece in the middle there that people can slice and dice in different ways, and it's still a very open sort of research question, is really around all the dialogue management. So you have the text coming in or the words coming in. Let's assume it's just written text because then you can always kind of model the speech and the voice side as at the other end of this pipeline. So you have text coming in.
你有这个理解能力，它的工作是决定它意味着什么，说的话或说的话意味着什么。我想这是最好的表达方式。然后它进入一个现在与对话管理器交互的结构中，或者，并且再次，那可以由几部分组成。但广义上讲，对话管理器的任务是获取该信息，并在对话到现在为止正在发生的事情的背景下理解它。有些管理器做了很多这方面的工作，有些管理器根本不做这方面的工作，但从逻辑上讲，这是系统这一部分的责任。
You have this understanding capability whose job it is to decide what it means what was said or what was said means. I guess it's the best way to say that. And then that comes in a structure now that interacts with the dialogue manager, or, you know, and again, that can kind of be a few pieces. But broadly speaking, dialogue manager's job is to take that information, understand it in the context of, you know, what's going on in the conversation up until now. Some managers do a lot of that and some managers do none of that, but logically that's the responsibility of this piece of the system.
然后将其转化为下一个动作。然后该下一个动作作为该下一个动作的一个元素传递出去。可能会发生很多事情，对吧？它可能会去调用一个 API 并检查你的银行余额或其他什么，但它也极有可能或大部分时间会导致想要向你发回一些文本。因此，在一个具有解耦的 NLG 组件的系统中，正如你之前提到的，它现在将发回这个元数据块，而 NLG 的任务将是去把它变成
And then to turn that into a next action. And then that next action gets passed out as like one element of that next action. There may be lots of things that happen, right? It may go call an API and check your balance for your bank or whatever it is, But it's also going to result very likely or most of the time in wanting to send you some text back. And so in a system that has a decoupled NLG component, as you mentioned before, it will send back now this metadata blob and the NLG's job will be to go and turn that into
语言，从而变成对话，对吧？所以这些我认为是，用大写的动物字母来说，就对话式人工智能系统而言，这些就是大块头。是的，这说得通。所以我想如果我没记错的话，《佐克》没有对话。它更像是拿起剑、击打巨魔，我的意思是，自我玩那个游戏以来已经过去很长时间了，但是，呃，很久以前就有带有对话的互动小说了，就像这个 sx1 一样，我确信它那个时代还有其他的小说。
language and thus kind of conversation, right? So those I think are the, like in big animal letters, so to speak, those are kind of the big blocks here as far as a conversational AI system goes. Yeah, that makes sense. So I think if I remember correctly, Zork didn't have conversation. It was more of like a pick up sword hit hit troll i mean it's been a long long time since i played that but but uh there have been interactive fictions with conversation from a long time ago like this sx1 i'm sure there are other ones of its era
而今天试图剖析它，我想他们当时在做的是，他们的磁盘上可能有一些 WordNet 本体，你知道的。所以我想也许他们在做的是，你知道的，他们拿走你对化身所说的话的句子，他们看着每一个词，他们可能正在遍历这个 WordNet，所以给人们一点背景知识，WordNet 基本上是英语语言的一个树状结构，它已经存在了很长时间，所以你可以想象，我记得根词是实体，如果我没记错的话。所以一切都是实体的子代，并且，你知道的，有对象和抽象。如果你要拿走比如，像快乐，快乐将是一种情绪，这是一种抽象，它是一个实体。所以你
and i and trying to unpack it today i i think what they were doing is they probably had some WordNet ontology, you know, on the disk. And so I think maybe what they were doing was, you know, they were taking your sentence of what you told the avatar and they were looking at each word and they were maybe traversing up this word net so just a bit of background for folks word net is basically a tree of the english language and it's been around for a very long time so you can imagine i think the root word is entity if i remember correctly so everything is a child of entity and um you know there's there's objects and abstractions so if you were to take like, like happy, happy would be an emotion, which is an abstraction, which is an entity. And so you
可以沿着这个链条向上走。所以如果我问 20 世纪 80 年代这个游戏中的化身，你知道，你快乐吗？或者你是，我不知道，我猜是兴高采烈或类似的东西。他们会做的是他们会沿着这个 WordNet 链向上走，然后他们可能手工思考过如果他们得到这些非常高级的词该怎么做，并且他们能够覆盖，你知道的，相当广泛的范围。所以我的猜测是有类似的东西，他们只是在提取单独的词。然后如果他们看到那个词，那么他们就知道，好的，这个人问了我关于钥匙的事，或者这个人问了我关于悲伤的事。所以开始悲伤的叙事，在这个叙事中这个人可以去进行这次探寻，让我不再悲伤，类似的事情。是的。不，我认为，并且我认为你随后描述了，你知道的，很多自然语言理解，你知道，曾经是什么以及某种
could kind of go up this chain. And so if I asked this avatar in this game from the 1980s, you know, are you happy? Or are you, I don't know, I guess elated or something like that. What they would do is they would go up this WordNet chain and then they probably by hand kind of thought about what to do if they get these really high level words and they were able to kind of cover, you know, a pretty broad range there. And so my guess is there's something like that and they were just pulling out individual words. And then if they see that word, then they know, okay, this person asked me about the key or the person asked me about being sad. So start the sad narrative where this person can go on this quest to make me not sad anymore, things like that. Yeah. Yeah. No, I think, and I think you described then like a lot of, you know, what natural language understanding, you know, was and kind
不得不长期成为什么，对吧？就像那样，有一些像那样的技术，你知道的，很多很多不同的、非常华丽的处理语言的方法，因为语言异常复杂，而对话甚至更是如此，对吧？就像这里的理解部分本身就是一个极其重要且巨大的研究工作，很长很长一段时间以来都是这样，对吧？而且我认为很多时候我们倾向于宣称它今天比实际情况要封闭得多。就像这也算是一个有趣的话题，那就是我们在自然语言理解方面到底有多好？我们在对话处理方面到底有多好？我的回答是，我们没有我们想象的那么好，无论是在学术背景下还是在专业背景下。
of had to be for a long time, right? And like that, there was there were sort of techniques like that, you know, a lot of a lot of like different, very ornate ways of dealing with language, because language is exceptionally complicated, and dialogue, even more so, right? Like just the understanding piece of this has been an extremely important and huge research effort for a long, long time, right? And I think a lot of times we sort of claim it's a lot more closed down today than it really is. Like that's sort of something interesting to talk about too, is like how good are we at natural language understanding? How good are we at dialogue handling? And my answer is, we're not as good as we think we are, neither in the academic nor in the professional context.
而做好这项工作的一部分是从这种认识开始的，然后意识到我们必须构建工具和能力来帮助我们达到我们 kind of、我们许多人某种程度上已经相信我们所处的水平。我认为这背后有很多原因。无论是在专业背景下还是在学术背景下都有炒作，这也将是一个有趣的话题。但确实，但你也看到了，实质性的进展是非常非常有意义的，就像我们在计算机视觉中看到的那样，从 2006 年开始，你知道的，神经网络方法的开始和第一种，你知道的，早期的自动编码器，对吧？那些开始改变那个问题的东西。然后是卷积神经网络的发展，你知道的，在这些网络中，网络某种程度上满足了系统本身的某些对称性。
And part of doing this work well is beginning with that recognition and then realizing that we have to build tools and capabilities to help us get to the level set where we kind of, where many of us kind of already believe we are. And I think there's a lot of reasons for that. There's hype in both the professional and the academic context, which would also be interesting to talk about. But I do, but you do see, you know, material advances that are very, very meaningful in the same way that we saw for computer vision, you know, starting back in 2006, you know, the beginning of a neural net approach and the first kind of, you know, early auto encoders, right. That, that start to change that problem around. And then the development of convolutional neural networks that, you know, where the, the network sort of satisfies some of the symmetries of this, of the system itself.
这使得它能够很好地工作，并很好地重塑这些网络的函数容量，使它们对我们之前讨论过的这些近似的局部极小值做出非常好的猜测，你在过去五到十年里开始在自然语言领域看到一些这种情况发生。但坦率地说，在我看来，这更困难，因为我可以谈论物理空间的对称性是什么，对吧？就像，向左移动，向右移动，向上移动，向下移动，旋转，反射。是的，我的意思是，如果你在训练某物
And that allows it to work really well and kind of reshape the functional capacity of these networks well enough so that they make really good guesses at these approximate local minima we were talking about before, you start to see some of that happen in the last five to 10 years in the natural language space. But it's frankly harder, in my opinion, because I can talk about what the symmetries of physical space are, right? Like, you know, move left, move right, move up, move down, rotate, reflect. Yeah, I mean, if you're training something
来下棋或类似的东西，你把棋盘翻转过来，你知道的，在它的轴上，你的策略不必改变，或者它是一个镜像策略。所以你甚至可以直接，你知道，把那个破解到系统中，现在它只需要学习一半的内容，但对于语言来说，完全不清楚那种对称性是什么。好吧，是的。我的意思是，语言中的对称性是什么，就像同义词或反义词。
to like play chess or something and you flip the board, you know, on its axis, your strategy doesn't have to change or it's a mirror strategy. And so you could even just directly, you know, hack that into the system and now it only has to learn half as much, but for language, it's totally unclear what that symmetry is. Well, yeah. I mean, what is it like a symmetry in language is like a synonym or an antonym.
是的，对吧。所以，你如何教电脑去理解这一点？对吧？而且我认为，如果你开始像那样把问题拆开，它就开始变得清晰了，或者至少你可以对为什么注意力机制真的很有意义，以及为什么现代应用程序的一些神经网络以它们所发生的方式发展做出一个很好的直观解释，因为它们试图解决其中一些对称性问题，采用的方式
Yeah, right. Right. And so, so how do you teach a computer to understand that? Right. And I think what, what, if you start to break the problems apart like that, like it starts to become clear, or at least you can make a good intuitive explanation for why attention mechanisms are really meaningful and why the neural nets for some of these modern applications have developed the way that they have, because they're trying to solve some of these symmetry problems in the
就像你和我一样。你通过上下文了解单词，对吧？而且我们非常擅长识别上下文的哪些元素实际上会相互影响，即使在长篇文本中也是如此。所以我认为我们已经开始学习其中的一些东西了。并且我认为最近显然有很多重大进展，区分了什么是炒作，或者拥有像 GPT-3 这样的东西取得进展意味着什么，例如，它真正擅长什么与它真正不擅长什么。我认为这实际上对我们来说在某些方面非常困难，因为它的工作性质。
same way that you and I do. You know words through context, right? And we're really good at recognizing which elements of context actually impact each other, even in a long form piece of text. So I think we've started to learn some of that. And I think obviously there's been a lot of major advances recently, separating out what's kind of hype or what it means to have advanced with something like a GPT-3, for example, like what that really is good at versus what it's really not good at. I think that's that's actually very hard for us in some ways because of the nature of what it's doing.
它正在产生，你知道的，如此引人注目的文本，以至于我们很难不去想象，你知道的，就像幕后有什么绿野仙踪式的实体。那是个无所不知的正在做这件事的存在，嗯，并且真正把它梳理出来。是的，我以为，我以为，嗯，有一项研究，我确信这是一个庞大的研究体系，但我认为这真的很有趣。我不记得它是使用生成对抗网络（GAN）还是 Transformer。我完全不记得了，但是，嗯，它会，嗯，它会为图像添加标题。所以你会给它一张图像，出来的会是，你知道的，一个女孩坐在红色秋千上，（你知道的）在树旁和一个男孩交谈。我当时觉得那太酷了。我的意思是，当我看到那个时，
It's producing, you know, such a such compelling text on its own that it's hard for us not to imagine, you know, like a like a some kind of wizard of Oz entity back there. That's like all knowing that's doing that, um, and really tease it out. Yeah. I thought the, I thought the, um, there's one research, I'm sure it's a whole body of research, but I thought it was really fascinating. I can't remember if it's using GANs or transformers. I don't totally remember, but, um, it would, um, it would caption an image. So you would give it an image and what would come out would be, you know, a girl is sitting on a red swing, you know, talking to a boy near a tree. And I thought that was so cool. I mean, when I saw that,
它能生成如此引人入胜的文本，以至于我们很难不去想象，你知道的，就像背后有什么“绿野仙踪”里的大魔法师实体一样。它就像是无所不知的幕后推手，真的能把潜力激发出来。是的。我觉得，我觉得，嗯，有一项研究——我确信这是一个庞大的研究领域——但我觉得它真的很吸引人。我记不清它是用了生成对抗网络（GAN）还是Transformer模型了。我完全记不清了，但是，嗯，它能够为图像生成描述。所以你给它一张图片，输出的结果就会是，你知道的，“一个女孩坐在红色的秋千上，在树旁和一个男孩说话”。我觉得这太酷了。我的意思是，当我看到那个时，
that blew my mind. And I felt like that. I mean, well, I actually, it would be great to know for your opinion. I mean, it could be, it could be hype because I don't know the tech that well, but I feel like we reached a milestone when I saw that paper. No, no, I a hundred percent agree with you. So the automatic image captioning is an example. It's almost an anti-example of like GPT in some ways, because what that's doing and it, and there's a long way to go there. I mean, you know, you're not going to, it's not going to approximate there. I mean, you know, you're not going to, it's not going to approximate, you know, really complex tasks. It's not going to handle really complex tasks the way that like you and I with the eloquence that you and I would,
这太让我震撼了。而且我当时就是这种感觉。我的意思是，其实，能听听你的看法就太好了。我的意思是，这可能，这可能是炒作，因为我对这项技术不是特别了解，但我觉得当我看到那篇论文时，我们已经达到了一个里程碑。不，不，我完全同意你的看法。所以自动图像标注就是一个例子。从某些方面来说，它几乎是GPT的反面例子，因为它的作用，而且还有很长的一回路要走。我的意思是，你知道，你不会去，它不会去近似，我的意思是，你知道，你不会去，它不会去近似，你知道，真正复杂的任务。它不会像你和我那样，或者像任何人类那样，以你我所具备的流畅度来处理非常复杂的任务，
or any human, but it did something fundamentally different, right? Which is to do that research, and a lot of this came out of Google, you know, in sort of the image search space, like there's, I think, a lot of genesis there. But to do that work well, what had to happen is you had to develop a shared mathematical representation of the visual image and of the text, right? And so the way you typically train models like this, I mean, it's been a while since I looked at this research, so this could have changed. But the last time I looked at it, which was several years ago, the way you typically train models like that is you have like, you know, two vectors, you know, one representing the, you know, the sort of vectorized form of the speech or the language, one representing the vectorized form of the image. And then you're trying to optimize their inner product. Right. So they're getting closer and closer together.
但它做了一件根本不同的事情，对吧？也就是做这项研究，其中很多成果都来自谷歌，你知道的，在图像搜索领域，我觉得有很多根源都在那里。但要把这项工作做好，必须发生的一件事是，你必须开发出视觉图像和文本的共享数学表示，对吧？所以你通常训练这种模型的方法是，我的意思是，我已经有一段时间没看这项研究了，所以这可能会有改变。但上次我看到的时候，也就是好几年前，你通常训练这种模型的方法是，你知道，有两个向量，一个表示语音或语言的向量化形式，另一个表示图像的向量化形式。然后你要去优化它们的内积。对吧。所以它们会越来越接近。
Yeah. Just to double click on that. So we had an episode, our last episode was with the CEO of Pinecone, and Pinecone is a vector similarity database. And we talked about how you could take sort of any classification problem, or even in an unsupervised or self-supervised way, you can kind of take a chunk of data and you can create a embedding or a very relatively low dimensional representation of that. And what Joe's here talking about is, you can actually do this with two different media and try to join them together
是的。我想就此深入探讨一下。所以我们有一期节目，我们上一期节目的嘉宾是Pinecone的首席执行官，Pinecone是一个向量相似性数据库。我们讨论了你可以采用某种分类问题，甚至以无监督或自监督的方式，你可以获取一块数据，然后你可以创建一个嵌入或一个相对低维的表示。乔在这里谈论的是，你实际上可以用两种不同的媒体来做这件事，并试着将它们结合起来，
when you've seen them together on the same website or if you have a hand curated set. And now you end up with two things that are projected into the same space and then you can go backwards with one of them. Yeah, that's exactly right. Sorry for not giving a little more background there. But to me, that's fascinating because it's like a step in teaching a system to have a multimodal representation of reality. Right. So now it's now the image and the text are in a shared space,
当你看到它们同时出现在同一个网站上，或者如果你有一套人工精选的数据集。现在你最终得到了两个被投影到相同空间中的东西，然后你可以用其中一个进行反向操作。是的，完全正确。抱歉刚才没有提供更多背景信息。但对我来说，这非常迷人，因为这就像是教导系统拥有现实的多模态表示的一个步骤。对吧。所以现在图像和文本处于一个共享空间中，
as you say, a shared mathematical space, a shared semantic space, which is how you and I work, right? Like we don't differentiate, you know, like the concept of red dress, you know, the words and the picture of that in a physical red dress, that's all, you know, those are all of a piece for us, right? Those are all related, like obviously very strongly, but it's just different representations of the same fundamental object. So I think that, and that's very much not what like GPT did. And don't get
正如你所说，一个共享的数学空间，一个共享的语义空间，这正是你我的工作方式，对吧？比如我们不会去区分，你知道的，比如红色连衣裙的概念，你知道的，文字以及实体红色连衣裙的图片，这些全部，你知道的，对我们来说都是一个整体，对吧？这些都是相关的，很明显联系非常强烈，但它只是对同一个基本对象的不同表示。所以我认为，这与GPT所做的事截然不同。别误会
me wrong, I'm not trying to talk trash about GPT. I think it's an amazing advancement. In some ways, I think we should think of these big language models as like national resources that we're building because they, I mean, it literally take as much power, like you measure the power required to train one of these things, like in units of Hoover Dam, like that kind of, that like, that's actually a reasonable scale. Like it's, I forget how many like Hoover Dam days it is to train GPT, but it's not like 0.0005 or anything. It's like a real number. Yep. Yep. And you can transfer learn off of it. So it really is. I think that's a beautiful way of looking at it. It really is like a real number. Yep. Yep. And you can transfer learn off of it. So it really is. I think that's a beautiful way of looking at it.
我的意思，我不是在贬低GPT。我认为这是一个了不起的进步。从某种意义上说，我认为我们应该把这些大语言模型看作是我们正在建造的国家资源，因为它们，我的意思是，这简直需要那么大的算力，比如你用胡佛水坝的单位来衡量训练其中一个模型所需的算力，就那种，那种，这其实是一个合理的规模。比如我忘了训练GPT需要多少个胡佛水坝日了，但它不是像0.0005之类的。这是一个真实的数字。是的。是的。而且你可以在它上面进行迁移学习。所以它确实是。我觉得这是一种绝佳的看待方式。它真的就像一个真实的数字。是的。是的。而且你可以在它上面进行迁移学习。所以它确实是。我觉得这是一种绝佳的看待方式。
It really is like a national treasure that we've all spent a ton of time and energy curating. And now everyone can benefit. Yeah. And with a whole bunch of infrastructure required to do it, right? You can't do that without the data centers. You can't go do that without, you know, industrial strength power lines going everywhere, right? Yada, yada, yada. But GPT is different, right? What it's trained on is not, and it's not trying to find this multimodal representation, right? It's trained on basically most of the text of the internet, right? So it's a window into what for us is like a projection of reality onto text, right?
它真的就像是我们所有人都花费了大量时间和精力策划的一件国宝。现在每个人都能受益。是的。而且需要一整套基础设施来完成它，对吧？没有数据中心，你做不到这一点。没有高强度电力线通往各处，你做不到这一点，对吧？等等等等。但GPT是不同的，对吧？它训练所基于的内容不是，它也不是在试图找到这种多模态表示，对吧？它的训练基本上基于互联网上绝大多数的文本，对吧？所以它是通往对我们来说像是一幅现实投影到文本之上的窗口，对吧？
That is GPT's reality, right? That's what it knows, right? Which is why, you know, and we start to think about it like that, like the ways in which the model is amazing and the ways in which the model is confusing, at least to me, start to make a little bit more sense, right? You can ask, so you think, all right, if I train this model on this and I ask it who the president of the United States is, and in 1815, it's going to give me a good answer because it's got all these good relations. It's got a bunch of techs to work with that could tell it that answer. I mean, obviously, it's an amazing
这就是GPT的现实，对吧？这就是它所了解的，对吧？这就是为什么，你知道，当我们开始这样看待它时，至少对我来说，这个模型的惊艳之处以及这个模型让人困惑的地方，开始变得更有意义了，对吧？你可以问，所以你想，好吧，如果我用这个来训练模型，然后我问它1815年美国总统是谁，它会给我一个很好的答案，因为它有所有这些良好的关联。它有一堆可以用来告诉它这个答案的文本。我的意思是，很明显，能够将这一点综合到一个能够进行推理的系统中，是一个了不起的
advance that we're able to synthesize that into a system that can make the inference. But then it's also like if you go and ask it, who was the president in 1705, right? Before the country was instantiated, it'll give you a reasonable answer of a person who's kind of sort of presidential, right? It could be like Ben Franklin or whoever, that's probably too early for Ben Franklin. But yeah, you can go and sort of trick it with these questions and these premises. And it doesn't do a great job, you know, without some further prompting and some further help in like understanding that that question doesn't make sense in that context, because it's this it's this really big and sophisticated association machine that doesn't have larger political context, like doesn't really understand what it means in the same
进步。但如果你去问它，1705年谁是总统，对吧？在这个国家建立之前，它会给你一个关于一个有点像总统的人的合理解答，对吧？可能是本杰明·富兰克林或者随便谁，对本杰明·富兰克林来说可能太早了。但是，是的，你可以去用这些问题和前提来捉弄它。在没有进行进一步提示和进一步帮助来理解该问题在该上下文中没有意义的情况下，它做得并不是很好，因为它是一个非常宏大且复杂的关联机器，它没有宏大的政治背景，比如并不同样地
way that you and I do for some of these historical events to have taken place. It's, it's really doing much more associative work. And a lot of that's that thin layer of like, it's just on this, like if language is kind of a membrane of our reality, right. You know, it's, it's stuck on that membrane and it can't escape. Yep. Yep. Yeah. I think so. Correct me if I'm wrong. GPT-3 is trained such that they take a string of N words and then they try and predict the next word, the N plus one word. And so what you end up with is now you can give GPT-3 a sentence or a paragraph or what have you. It will generate the next word that it feels like belongs there. So what you just described is fundamentally what a language
真正理解其中一些历史事件的发生意味着什么。它，它其实在做更多关联性的工作。其中很大一部分是那一层薄薄的东西，它只是在这个上面，如果语言就像是我们现实的一层膜的话，对吧。你知道的，它，它就粘在那层膜上，无法逃脱。是的。是的。是的。我想是的。如果我错了请纠正我。GPT-3的训练方式是，它们取一串N个单词，然后尝试预测下一个单词，即第N+1个单词。所以最终的结果是，现在你可以给GPT-3一个句子、一个段落或诸如此类的东西。它将生成它觉得属于那里的下一个单词。所以你刚才描述的从根本上来说就是语言
model is. And GPT-3 is a language model, right? So mathematically, the definition of a language model is given n words, predict the n plus first. And however you get there, however you want to do that, that could be a set of rules in the background, that could be whatever, like some algorithms got to do that job. And then once you have, the reason that's an important construct in the field is that once you have that, it unlocks all these other things, right? It's like, now I can turn that prediction and the underlying representations of the text and the knowledge that fuel it into really many of the applications that we care about today. So it's kind of a building block. And so GPT, and you train these language models in
模型。而GPT-3是一个语言模型，对吧？所以在数学上，语言模型的定义是给定n个单词，预测第n+1个。无论你如何达到这个目标，无论你想怎么做，那可以是一套后台规则，也可以是别的什么，比如某种算法必须完成这项工作。一旦你有了，该领域中这是一个重要结构的原因是，一旦你有了它，它就会解锁所有这些其他东西，对吧？这就好比，现在我可以把那个预测以及文本的基础表示和为其提供动力的知识，转化为我们今天关心的真正许多应用。所以它有点像一个构建块。因此，GPT，你以
different ways. You don't always train it, specifically train it only with that task. That is the mathematical sort of fundamental definition of what task a language model has to perform, but there's lots of transfer learning like different ways you get the model to be good at doing that. And then of course, on the other side, there's a bunch of applications you'll go and you go and turn on for it. So, but a lot of, yeah, a lot of this sort of self-supervised aspect of training language models is really about, you know, making adjudications of how good or how well a word fits in its context. And the nice thing about something like GPD3 is that although you have to use, you know, Hoover damn day's worth of energy, you don't have to
不同的方式训练这些语言模型。你并不总是训练它，专门只用那个任务来训练它。那是语言模型必须执行的任务的数学意义上的基本定义，但有很多迁移学习，比如让模型擅长这样做的不同方法。当然，在另一端，还有一堆你可以去为它开启的应用。所以，但是，是的，训练语言模型的这种自监督方面的很大一部分，实际上是关于，你知道的，对一个单词在其上下文中适合的程度或好坏做出判断。像GPD3这样的东西的好处在于，尽管你必须使用，你知道的，价值一个胡佛水坝日的能量，但你不需要
do any manual labeling because it's self-supervised. It's just scanning this data from the internet and it's trying to learn the rhythm of this data and it can just see right away, did I predict this word correctly or not, without any human intervention. Yeah, no, that's why it's powerful and that's also why it's limited. There's only so much you can learn that way, but there's a lot you can learn that way. And as a baseline for learning other things, it's kind of the best one we've got right now. That's why people are so excited about it. And it's pretty cool. I mean, we didn't have anything like this 15 years ago. And now we have models that can tell us stories that really are, you know, rapturous that it wrote about itself, right. Is a, like an amazing way to illustrate that. Hey guys, we're onto something new here. Like this is where, you know, we're in Star Trek territory kind of sort of a little bit.
做任何手动标注，因为它是自监督的。它只是在扫描互联网上的这些数据，并试图学习这些数据的节奏，它可以立刻看出，我是否正确预测了这个单词，而不需要任何人类的干预。是的，不，这就是它强大的地方，这也是它局限的地方。通过这种方式你只能学到这么多，但通过这种方式你可以学到很多。作为学习其他东西的基线，它算是我们现在拥有的最好的基线。这就是为什么人们对它如此兴奋。而且它相当酷。我的意思是，15年前我们没有任何类似的东西。而现在我们有了可以给我们讲故事的模型，这些故事真的是，你知道的，狂喜的，它关于它自己写的内容，对吧。是一个，用来阐明这一点的绝妙方式。嘿，伙计们，我们这里有了新发现。这就是，你知道的，我们有点进入了星际迷航的领域。
Yeah. So, so bring us back down to earth. In my opinion, I feel like there's two big pieces that are missing and there's probably a lot more, but, but I'd love to get your take on it. I think one piece that's missing is getting uncertainty estimations from really any of these models. And so to your point, you say, what is the American president in 59 BC? The model should just say, well, I'm not confident about anything here, right? And then the second point is having some kind of symbolic understanding to where, you know, it can understand, you know, in a modular way, it can understand and compartmentalize,
好的，所以，把我们拉回现实。在我看来，我觉得有两个缺失的大块，可能还有更多，但是，但是我很想听听你的看法。我认为缺失的一个部分是从这些模型中获得不确定性估计。所以根据你的观点，你说，公元前59年的美国总统是谁？模型应该直接说，嗯，我对这里的任何事情都没有信心，对吧？然后第二点是具备某种符号理解能力，这样，你知道的，它可以理解，你知道的，以一种模块化的方式，它可以理解并将其区隔化，
you know, America as a concept and when that concept started. And you can use like some first order predicate logic to say, well, you know, the question is invalid because of these, these sort of symbols. I think that we've gone to this sort of this, this embedding soup. And because of that, we've lost the ability to, to think about things and reason about things in like a logical methodical search kind of based way. And I feel like those are the two, at least in my opinion, the two big missing pieces. Yeah, they're both really, really interesting and they're great points. Let me try and like at least take on one of them. Maybe we'll get to both because I love to talk
你知道的，美国作为一个概念以及这个概念是何时开始的。你可以使用某种一阶谓词逻辑来表示，嗯，你知道，由于这些，这些符号的存在，这个问题是无效的。我认为我们已经进入了这种，这种嵌入的“肉汤”中。正因为如此，我们失去了以一种逻辑的、有条理的搜索式的方式来思考事情和推理事情的能力。我觉得这两点，至少在我看来，是两个缺失的大块。是的，它们都非常非常有趣，而且都是很好的观点。让我试着至少承担其中一个。也许我们会两个都谈到，因为我很喜欢谈论
about both. So as far as like the logic point that you make, I, so look, I agree with both your points. First of all, I think those things are missing. I think the logical element or the higher order logic, we don't know how to teach computers to do well. I personally don't think the answer is, at least not in as flexible a way as you and I do it when we sort of think through the universe as we do. I don't think the answer is to construct a kind of symbology of it, right? That, that, that like, then these inferences are going to like be mapped into, and then, and then there'll be some, like some kind of logical computation that happens on the symbology. And then that's going to go back to the, to the embedding space and like, give it a different, I don't think, I actually don't think that'll work. I mean, I could be wrong. What do I know? I'm just, just, just one, one guy. But the reason I think that space, like
这两点。至于你提出的逻辑观点，我，所以你看，我同意你的两点。首先，我认为这些东西是缺失的。我认为逻辑元素或高阶逻辑，我们不知道如何教计算机做好。我个人认为答案不是，至少不是以你和我那样灵活的方式，在我们像现在这样思考宇宙时那样。我认为答案不是去构建一种它的符号学，对吧？然后，这些推理将被映射到其中，然后，然后将会产生某种，某种对符号学进行的逻辑计算。然后这将返回到嵌入空间中，并赋予它一个不同的，我不认为，我其实不认为这会行得通。我的意思是，我可能是错的。我知道什么？我只是，只是，只是一个普通人。但我认为那个空间的原因，就像
that space of like, what is, what are the constructs and what are the abstractions that we use to make decisions at the higher order logic is itself just as complicated as the reality it's trying to simplify. Right. In terms of like the relations between the constructs and the boundaries, a lot of things are complicated because the boundaries around what, what is this construct versus, you versus not, like what's in the set and what's not in the set are just hard questions. And so I think in the end, we're going to have to find a way to teach a machine to construct representations like that for itself, right? But there is going to have to be some notion or some parallel process that serves the same function of the logical hierarchies that you and I would use. And like, you know, we teach humans how to do that. Right. And, and, and sometimes, you know, when you get into like deep political disagreements, like sometimes at the root of that is just a, like a, you know, kind of a misalignment
那个关于“什么是，我们在高阶逻辑中用于做出决策的构造和抽象是什么”的空间，其本身就和它试图简化的现实一样复杂。对吧，就构造之间的关系和边界而言，很多事情之所以复杂，是因为关于这个构造是什么与你、与不是你之间的边界，比如什么在集合内什么不在集合内，都只是很难的问题。所以我认为最终，我们将不得不找到一种方法来教机器为自己构建这样的表示，对吧？但必须有一些概念或并行进程，来发挥你我将使用的逻辑层次结构的相同功能，而且，你知道的，我们教人类如何做到这一点。对吧，而且，而且，有时候，当你陷入像深刻的政治分歧时，有时这的根源仅仅是，你知道的，一种，对其中一些类别定义的错位。
of some of these definitions of, of categories. I think just to riff on that, like one thing that I think paves away is the Mew Zero. I don't know if you've been following Mew Zero from DeepMind, but DeepMind, their claim to fame or their initial claim to fame was beating the world master at Go. So Go is this board game. It's just a lot more complicated in terms of branching and other stuff than chess. And they were able to beat Lisa Dahl. And now a computer is the world Go champion. But they didn't stop there. The next thing they did is they built something called AlphaZero.
我想顺着这个话题说下去，我认为铺平道路的一件事是Mu0。我不知道你有没有关注来自DeepMind的Mu0，但是DeepMind，他们的成名作或最初的成名作是击败了围棋世界冠军。所以围棋是一种棋盘游戏。就分支和其他方面而言，它比国际象棋复杂得多。他们能够击败李世石。现在电脑是世界围棋冠军。但他们并没有止步于此。他们做的下一件事是构建了一个名为AlphaZero的东西。
And AlphaZero removed all of the Go-specific logic. And it treated it as just a field of... Now, they did have to do some feature engineering, right? So you can imagine, you know, Go has just white and black stones. Chess doesn't. Chess has a whole bunch of variety. And so you have to do some proper feature engineering.
而AlphaZero去除了所有围棋特有的逻辑。它把它当作一个领域对待……现在，他们确实得做一些特征工程，对吧？所以你可以想象，你知道的，围棋只有白棋和黑棋。国际象棋没有。国际象棋有各种各样的棋子。所以你必须做一些适当的特征工程。
But, you know, beyond that, the rules of Go and all these tricks were not in AlphaZero, and it was able to perform just as well as AlphaGo. But what they did have written by hand is the game tree. So when they're doing this game tree search, the mechanics of Go are built into that. So in other words, AlphaZero will say and and this now it's alpha zero so it works on many games alpha zero will say take this move this go move this checkers move this chess move and then that would go into some program that a person wrote that would make the move
但是，你知道，除此之外，围棋的规则和所有这些技巧都不在AlphaZero中，它的表现和AlphaGo一样好。但他们确实手写了游戏树。所以在他们做这个游戏树搜索时，围棋的机制是内置在其中的。换句话说，AlphaZero会说，而且现在它是alpha zero，所以它适用于许多游戏，alpha zero会说，走这一步，走这个围棋步，走这个跳棋步，走这个国际象棋步，然后这会进入某个由人编写的程序，该程序会走这一步，
you know adjust the game appropriately tell them if they want or not and then um um and then it would go and then it would uh and then that would conclude a simulation. So they would simulate using the hand-coded engine after so many simulations and they have a good action, right? So then they took it to the next level with Mu0, where in Mu0, they don't even use the rules of the game. And so actually in the neural network, they don't even use the rules of the game. And so actually in the neural network,
适当地调整游戏，告诉他们是赢了还是输了，然后，呃，呃，然后它会继续，然后它会，然后那将结束一场模拟。所以他们在使用手写引擎进行了多次模拟之后，会得到一个好的动作，对吧？然后他们用Mu0将其提升到了一个新的水平，在Mu0中，他们甚至不使用游戏规则。所以实际上在神经网络中，他们甚至不使用游戏规则。所以实际上在神经网络中，
it has to represent the rules of the game and it actually has to do the simulation in the neural net. I think they're using like an NLSTM or a transformer or something. And so literally they've gotten to a point now where you give it a go board and it thinks for a while and it does all these simulations and it just comes back and it says, you know, place the stone here. And I feel like that they're starting to unpack that, that planning and that reasoning and
它必须表示游戏规则，并且它实际上必须在神经网络中进行模拟。我想他们用的是类似LSTM或Transformer之类的东西。所以字面意思上，他们现在已经达到了这样一种程度：你给它一个围棋棋盘，它思考一会儿，进行所有这些模拟，然后它回来就说，你知道，把棋子放在这里。我觉得他们开始解开那个，那个规划、那个推理和
that symbology. It's totally uninterpretable to us, but they're starting to unpack that process, which I think is really exciting. Yeah. I mean, it's kind of like if you had a child, right. And you, you asked them to, like, you never told them how to play the game, but you just let them watch, you know, a bunch of people play, like, would they like, how well would they do in understanding the rules? And could they construct that abstraction? That's probably like, you know, easier for some people, harder for others, but fundamentally possible, right? We wouldn't see that as beyond us.
那个符号学。这对我们来说完全是不可解释的，但他们开始解开这个过程，我认为这真的令人兴奋。是的。我的意思是，这有点像如果你有一个孩子，对吧。然后你，你让他们，就像你从未告诉他们怎么玩这个游戏，但你只是让他们看，你知道，一群人玩，就像，他们会，他们理解规则的程度如何？他们能构建出那种抽象吗？这可能就像，你知道的，对某些人来说更容易，对另一些人来说更难，但从根本上说是可能的，对吧？我们不会认为这超出了我们的能力范围。
I think it's interesting. Yeah, I think you're right. I think that is like, I like the is that that playing field, so to speak, or that area of, you know, board games like that is so ridiculously simpler than, you know, than any like sort of knowledge or human conversation or language-based, you know, kind of real application that we have.
我觉得这很有趣。是的，我觉得你是对的。我认为那种，我喜欢那种竞技场，可以说是这样，或者说那种围棋之类棋盘游戏的领域，比起任何知识、人类对话或基于语言的我们拥有的那种真实应用，要简单得离谱。
I used to give these talks where I would talk about like, okay, everybody who's learning a lot about machine learning, and I'm not trying to put you in this box, you just referenced something in my mind, but everybody who's trying to first learn or who kind of sort of first learns about how to get machine learning done in one context rolls into the conversational context and they have kind of the same idea, right? Which is they're like, cool, have kind of the same idea, right? Which is they're like, cool, I just, I need a feedback loop here, right? Like I just need, what I need is like somebody, you know, a person's talking to the computer and like good thing happens or bad thing happens at the end.
我过去常常做这样的演讲，谈论，好吧，每一个正在深入学习机器学习的人，我不是要把你框在这个盒子里，你只是让我脑子里想起了某个东西，但每一个试图首先学习或以某种方式首先学习如何在某种情况下完成机器学习的人，都会一头扎进对话语境中，他们都有着同样的想法，对吧？也就是他们觉得，酷，有着同样的想法，对吧？也就是他们觉得，酷，我只是，我这里需要一个反馈回路，对吧？就像我只需要，我需要的是像某个人，你知道的，一个人在和计算机对话，然后最后发生好的事情或坏的事情。
And then I, and as soon as I have that, I'm going to like, going to do this self-optimization thing because that's what machine, that's how machine learning works. And there's a reason no systems work like that in the world. There are pieces of systems that work like that in real applications, but there is no end-to-end trained dialogue machine that means anything to any person that's used for real applications that is in that closed-loop form. And it fundamentally comes down to how complex the space of language and dialogues really is. And even though the space of Go, in a mathematical perspective, is vastly complex, right? And two to the, whatever, 113 or 111,
然后我，一旦我有了这个，我就会去，去做这个自我优化的事情，因为那是机器学习，那是机器学习工作的方式。这就是为什么世界上没有任何系统是这样工作的。在真实应用中，有部分系统是那样工作的，但没有任何一个端到端训练的对话机器，对任何用于真实应用的人有任何意义，是采用那种闭环形式的。这归根结底取决于语言和对话的空间到底有多复杂。尽管从数学角度来看，围棋的空间极其复杂，对吧？二的，随便什么，113次方或111次方，
or how many points there are on the board, kind of combinations of stones and all this stuff. Like those are huge numbers. But when you start with language, you begin with what is literally mathematically an infinite dimensional vector space. Yep. Yep. And the other part of it is there's no ambiguity in Go. I mean, you place the stone and the same thing happens every single time and there's no room for interpretation. But for language, it's the exact opposite. I mean, you couldn't build a language that didn't rely on assumptions. I mean, if you do, you kind of end up with something like a computer language, right? Yeah, that's right. That's sort of where that goes in a lot of ways.
或者棋盘上有多少个点，棋子组合的各种情况以及所有这些东西。像那些都是巨大的数字。但当你从语言开始时，你所开始的是字面意义上数学上的无限维向量空间。是的。是的。而另一部分是，围棋中没有歧义。我的意思是，你放下棋子，每一次发生的事情都完全一样，没有解释的空间。但对于语言，情况恰恰相反。我的意思是，你无法构建一个不依赖假设的语言。我的意思是，如果你这样做了，你最终会得到类似计算机语言的东西，对吧？是的，没错。在很多方面，这正是它的发展方向。
And I mean, those are obviously meaningful and interesting, but like, you know, nobody talks in Python for a reason. Right. Except Patrick, but nobody else. Yeah. Well, that's actually interesting because it's another thing GPT is really good at. It's really good at writing computer code out of language, which I think is a fascinating application.
我的意思是，这些显然是有意义的和有趣的，但是，你知道，没有人会无缘无故地说Python。对吧。帕特里克除外，但没有其他人。是的。嗯，这其实很有趣，因为这是GPT非常擅长的另一件事。它非常擅长用语言编写计算机代码，我认为这是一个迷人的应用。
Right. They call it, they're calling it Codex. Yeah. There's like a few different ways this has come to life. So, you know, there's a bunch of people that have done... You can go poke through Twitter and find all sorts of good examples of... You can literally build a front end in some cases by telling the machine what you want the web page to look like.
对吧。他们管这叫，他们叫它Codex。是的。有几种不同的方式让它变成了现实。所以，你知道，有一群人已经做到了……你可以去推特上浏览一下，找到各种各样的好例子……在某些情况下，你甚至可以通过告诉机器你希望网页长什么样来构建一个前端。
Oh, I've seen those demos. They're amazing. But to your other point... Sorry, we kind of meandered a bit. But to your other point, right? So sorry, we kind of meandered a bit. But to your other point around uncertainty, I also really, really agree with that, I think. And I think it's a big problem in conversational AI, right? Like you have these models that are built on, you know, especially natural language understanding that are built on these transformers and these embedded representations. And they're, you know, really good. In a lot of ways, they're, you know, really good in a lot of ways. They're very smart, but
哦，我见过那些演示。它们太棒了。但针对你的另一点……抱歉，我们有点扯远了。但针对你的另一点，对吧？所以抱歉，我们有点扯远了。但针对你关于不确定性的另一点，我也真的，真的很赞同这一点，我想。我认为这是对话式AI中的一个大问题，对吧？就像你有这些建立在，你知道的，尤其是建立在这些Transformer和嵌入表示之上的自然语言理解模型。它们是，你知道的，真的很棒。在很多方面，它们是，你知道的，在很多方面真的很棒。它们非常聪明，但
they can make really dumb mistakes still, right? That's not beyond them. And so most industrial strength models, most real systems have some, you know, sort of are forced to have some combination of rules and backstops against these, you know, neural network approaches. And I think a lot of what's under that or a lot of what's under that, or a lot of what's missing is, is there a system around that has a good idea about how good this natural language understanding system is likely to be at this problem?
它们仍然可能会犯非常愚蠢的错误，对吧？这并非不可能发生。所以大多数工业级模型，大多数真实系统都必须有一些，你知道的，被迫结合了针对这些神经网络方法的规则和后备机制。我认为这背后的很大一部分，或者背后的很大一部分，或者缺失的很大一部分是，周围是否存在这样一个系统：它对这个自然语言理解系统在这个问题上表现得有多好有一个很好的概念？
And my personal opinion, and some of the research work that we're doing, is that you actually need that system to be fairly decoupled from the system whose job it is to make the prediction in the first place. I think you can't have zero coupling and the art of it is kind of like in what way is, let's say the natural language understanding understander decoupled and in what ways is it coupled to the system itself?
我个人的意见，以及我们正在做的一些研究工作，是你实际上需要让那个系统与首要任务是做出预测的系统保持相当程度的解耦。我认为你不能做到零解耦，其中的艺术有点像，比如说，自然语言理解理解器在什么方式上是解耦的，它在什么方式上与系统本身是耦合的？
That's kind of like the hairy edge of this problem. But I think we haven't done a great job at that yet. And I think there's a lot of research, not we personally, but like we as a culture. And I think there's a lot of research still to be done. And I think it'll be important because I think it'll foundationalize some of the other problems that you talked about, right? So if we want to start building a better hierarchy of understanding for some of these models, a step on the way there is to ask, well, when is it wrong? Have a separate
这有点像这个问题的棘手边缘。但我认为我们在这一点上还没有做好。而且我认为有很多研究，不是我们亲自做，而是作为人类整体。我认为还有很多研究要做。而且我认为这很重要，因为我认为它将为我们讨论过的一些其他问题奠定基础，对吧？所以如果我们想开始为其中一些模型构建更好的理解层次结构，其中的一个步骤就是问，嗯，什么时候它是错的？对于这些模型什么时候是错的，有一个独立的
opinion about when these models are wrong, which can help us develop separate understanding of the categories of types of times when these models are wrong. So you can start to imagine an interplay, right? If I separate that system enough, it's going to begin to categorize, you know, a whole slew of cases where this thing is wrong that it doesn't know about. And then those slew of cases become the basis for an abstraction of, okay, what's a knowledge center,
看法，这可以帮助我们对这些模型出错的类别、类型和时间形成独立的理解。所以你可以开始想象一种相互作用，对吧？如果我把那个系统充分隔离开来，它就会开始对这个东西出错但它自己又不知道的大量案例进行分类。然后这大量案例就成为对以下问题进行抽象的基础，即，什么是知识中心，
you know, that this thing, where this thing is weak. Yep, yep, yeah, totally. Yeah, I think as a field, handling uncertainty is very, very difficult right now with, with deep networks. I mean, there's, and this is, you know, this is for something simple, like a supervised model. Let's say the model that predicts cats and dogs or something. I mean, it's, it's, there's, there's still not any consensus. I mean, there's effectively two or three camps. There's one camp that says, well, train, you know, 10 different models, either on one-tenth of the data or you shuffle the data for each model. And then now you'll get 10 different answers. And so, you know, depending on how much those answers vary, you can say how confident you are. There's another camp that is effectively doing the same thing, but within the model.
你知道的，这个东西，这个东西薄弱的地方。是的，是的，是的，完全同意。是的，我认为作为一个领域，目前深度网络处理不确定性非常非常困难。我的意思是，而且这是，你知道的，这对于像监督模型这样简单的事情来说也是如此。比方说预测猫和狗之类的模型。我的意思是，这仍然没有任何共识。我的意思是，实际上有两三个阵营。有一个阵营说，好吧，训练，你知道的，10个不同的模型，要么用十分之一的数据，要么为每个模型打乱数据。然后现在你会得到10个不同的答案。所以，你知道的，根据这些答案的变化程度，你可以说明你的信心有多大。还有一个阵营实际上在做同样的事情，但在模型内部进行，
So, you know, you kind of multiply the layers and now you have this distribution. And then there's this camp that says, let's put priors on everything and use kind of Bayesian approaches. And none of them work very well. I mean, the reason why you can't just go on pytorch.org or tensorflow.com or whatever and just get a model with uncertainty is because there's not really a method that satisfies it very well. There's a lot of reasons for that, but I think one of the most important ones is it sort of broadly goes under the header of like length, like processes that generate language and how varied they are. Right. And so I think, you know, this is one of the things we see in an industrial context all the time is that you can have models that are great and doing well, you know, based on real live training data from real live people that really live talk to the model and that you have now learned to correctly predict. And then something very subtle about the underlying environment can change. People can start talking about the business
所以，你知道的，你把各层相乘，现在你有了这个分布。然后还有这样一个阵营，说让我们在所有事情上都加上先验，并使用类似贝叶斯的方法。它们没有一个效果很好的。我的意思是，为什么你不能直接去pytorch.org或tensorflow.com或任何地方获取一个带有不确定性的模型，是因为没有一种方法能很好地满足它。这有很多原因，但我认为其中最重要的一点是，它大致属于诸如“长度”，诸如生成语言的过程以及它们有多么多样化这样的标题之下。对吧。所以我认为，你知道的，这是我们在工业环境中经常看到的事情之一，那就是你可能会有非常出色且表现良好的模型，你知道的，这是基于来自真实活生生的人类的真实活生生训练数据，这些人类真的与模型对话，而你现在已经学会了正确预测。然后底层环境的一些非常微妙的事情可能会发生变化。人们可能开始以不同的方式谈论商业
promotion in a different way because now there's an advertisement that describes in a different way. And all of a sudden, some of these things really start to fall apart. This is one of the areas that for me that illustrates like why NLU kind of isn't where we think it should be or where we think it is. And I think that, you know, mathematically what's going on under that is that, you know, there's the generating function for language and the infinite dimensionality of this vector space, right? Or, you know, allow for, they make it very hard to train models that
促销，因为现在有一个以不同方式描述它的广告。突然之间，其中一些事情真的开始崩溃了。这是对我而言阐明NLU为什么没有达到我们认为它应该达到或我们认为它所处的位置的领域之一。而且我认为，你知道的，在数学上底层发生的事情是，你知道的，存在语言的生成函数和这个向量空间的无限维性，对吧？或者，你知道的，允许，它们使得训练那些
are really rooted in the semantics as much as we'd like. And probably, you know, in the same way that, you know, GPT is existing on this membrane and, you know, really only seeing what it can see and missing these big pieces of reality and not having some of this like base symbolism to attach to, you know, the models that are doing the work of conversational AI today are still a little bit, you know, they can be infected with problems like that. And they can be confused by what we call lexical cues, more so than we'd like, right? So a lexical cue, for those who don't know, is just like something more on the surface of language about the word choice and the top level design of the words in the sentence versus semantic, which is like, okay, what's that deeper, you know, agreed upon meaning.
真正植根于语义的模型的难度大大增加，就像我们希望的那样。而且可能，你知道的，就像，你知道的，GPT存在于这层膜上，你知道的，真的只能看到它能看到的东西，并且错过了现实的这些大块，也没有一些可以附着的这种基础符号，今天从事对话式AI工作的模型仍然有点，你知道的，它们可能会被诸如此类的问题所感染。而且它们可能比我们希望的更容易被我们所说的词汇线索所困惑，对吧？所以，对于那些不知道的人来说，词汇线索只是一种关于语言表面上关于词语选择和句子中词语顶级设计的东西，而语义则是，好吧，什么是更深层的、大家达成共识的含义。
Yeah. I mean, one thing, one, one really prime example of that is cats and dogs, right? I think that, you know, we always hear that analogy, like it's raining cats and dogs, or this person's a dog lover, this person's a cat lover. And so our mental model, you know, as a society is that cats and dogs are opposite. And all of us as a child grew up watching movies where cats and dogs didn't like each other. Right. I mean, that's a trope. Right. And so in our mind, cats and dogs are really far apart. But if you were to use GPT-3, it's going to put them right next to each other. And the reason is websites that talk about cats, a lot of them talk about dogs, too.
是的。我的意思是，一个，一个真正主要的例子就是猫和狗，对吧？我认为，你知道的，我们总是听到那个类比，就像“雨下得像猫和狗一样大”（倾盆大雨），或者这个人是个爱狗人士，这个人是个爱猫人士。所以我们的心理模型，你知道的，作为社会群体，猫和狗是对立的。我们所有人从小看着电影长大，电影里猫和狗互相不喜欢。对吧。我的意思是，这是一个陈词滥调。对吧。所以在我们心中，猫和狗相距甚远。但如果你使用GPT-3，它会把它们放在紧挨着彼此的位置。原因在于谈论猫的网站，其中很多也谈论狗。
I mean, imagine a website that sells pet food. Right. I mean, they're going to be talking about cats and dogs at the same time. And so actually when you look at anything unsupervised, it's going to put cats and dogs very close together, especially in the grand scheme of anything that could be talked about. But we have this sort of a cultural separation and those kinds of things are just very hard to put into the model in any meaningful way. Yeah. I mean, I think what you hope is that scenarios like that will be accomplished via the high dimensionality of the embedding space, right? You can learn about some of that because on some dimensions, and high dimensionality is really hard to visualize, as I'm sure you
我的意思是，想象一个销售宠物食品的网站。对吧。我的意思是，它们会同时谈论猫和狗。所以实际上，当你查看任何无监督的内容时，它会把猫和狗放在非常接近的位置，尤其是在任何可以谈论的事情的宏大计划中。但我们有这种文化上的隔离，而这类事情很难以任何有意义的方式放入模型中。是的。我的意思是，我认为你希望的是，通过嵌入空间的高维性来实现这样的场景，对吧？你可以了解其中的一些，因为在某些维度上，高维性真的很难可视化，正如我确信你
know, and really hard to have intuition about because the distance metrics and all this start to behave really weird. But you would hope that there'd be some dimensionality where there's like this separation, right, which in our minds would correspond to like a character of the animal, or something like that, rather than a, you know, a functional view of the system, right? Because we're also not surprised when we go into a pet store and we see cat food next to dog food, right? That doesn't make us say, what's wrong with this world, right? So we have those separate dimensions or something. So I would hope that the representations can accommodate that. But I think the challenge to go back to the earlier point is, you know, what are those
所知道的那样，而且很难有直觉，因为距离度量和所有这些开始表现得非常奇怪。但你希望会有某种维度，在那种维度上存在这种分离，对吧，在我们的脑海中，这对应于动物的特征，诸如此类，而不是系统的功能视图，对吧？因为当我们走进宠物店，看到猫粮旁边放着狗粮时，我们也不会感到惊讶，对吧？这不会让我们说，这个世界怎么了，对吧？所以我们有那些独立的维度或类似的东西。所以我希望这些表示能够适应这一点。但我认为回归到先前观点的挑战在于，你知道的，那些
underlying dimensions? They're not stable, right? Like if I slant a concept like slightly differently, we might, we might redimensionalize that space a little bit differently. And, and so we sort of make them up on the fly in a lot of ways. Obviously, there's some touchstones, but there's something that we create dynamically. How do we interact with models at that level through the training process or through even a discursive process in dealing with them? Which is another thing I really like about GPT-3 is that you now talk to the model by giving it examples and can train it with real language. That's also in advance, I think is very important. And we're going to need to kind of cope with that and figure out how we use it because ultimately the better these things are at creating abstractions
底层的维度是什么？它们是不稳定的，对吧？如果我稍微不同地倾斜一个概念，我们可能会把那个空间重新降维得稍微有点不同。而且，因此我们在很多方面都是即兴编造它们的。显然，有一些基准，但这是我们动态创造的东西。我们如何在训练过程中，甚至在处理它们的论述过程中，在那个层面上与模型进行交互？这是我真的很喜欢GPT-3的另一件事，即你现在可以通过向模型提供示例来与它对话，并且可以用真实的语言来训练它。这也是一个进步，我认为这非常重要。我们将需要设法应对这一点，并弄清楚我们如何使用它，因为最终，这些东西在创造抽象
and redimensionalizing, you know, what they're talking about in the ways that we're kind of discussing, you know, the more we're going to need to converse with them to make sure we understand how their minds are working in the same way that when you and I talk to each other, like we got to get to a baseline about like, is he, you know, what does, is he actually a dog hater? Like I have to kind of figure that out first to talk to you appropriately about dogs or something. Yeah. I wonder if, if someone, you know, so if, if OpenAI is going to train a new GPT model, I wonder if they started with books for babies and, and, you know, the random network was biased in, in favor of baby's books. And then they literally trained it on books meant for older
和重新降维方面越好，你知道的，它们在谈论我们正在讨论的这些事情，你知道的，我们就越需要与它们对话，以确保我们了解它们的思维方式，就像你和我交谈时，你知道的，我们得达成一个基线，关于，他是，你知道的，他真的是一个恨狗的人吗？我必须先把这个弄清楚，才能和你适当地谈论狗或类似的事情。是的，我在想，如果有人，你知道的，所以，如果OpenAI要训练一个新的GPT模型，我在想，如果他们从婴儿的书籍开始，并且，你知道的，随机网络偏向于婴儿的书籍。然后他们真的用面向更老的人群的
and older people. And so it kind of followed the same path as a human in terms of what kind of material they consume. I wonder what that model would presuppose. I feel like there's something maybe really interesting there. Yeah, yeah, I agree. I think you quickly end up in the world of AGI, right? It's artificial general intelligence. And that definitely by no means an expert there. But I think that's kind of where a lot of this stuff goes in the end. It's like, well, I have to start teaching these things more like they're a child. And I have to start relying. And again, this is why uncertainty is so important. I have to start relying on their own understanding of themselves and their ability to express their understanding
书籍来训练它。所以它在消耗材料的类型方面基本上遵循了与人类相同的路径会怎样？我很想知道那个模型会预设什么。我觉得这其中可能有什么非常有趣的东西。是的，是的，我同意。我认为你很快就会进入AGI的世界，对吧？也就是通用人工智能。而且我绝对绝不是那里的专家。但我认为这正是很多这类东西最终的归宿。这就好比，好吧，我必须开始像教孩子一样教这些东西。而且我必须开始依赖。再次强调，这就是为什么不确定性如此重要。我必须开始依赖它们对自身的理解以及它们表达自己理解的能力。
of themselves in order to influence them in the ways that I want to and have them take right actions. And so you see it sort of quickly starts to, if you really break it down, I think you start thinking like, wait a second, I've got to imagine this as more like a human thing that I'm teaching and less like a mathematical process that I'm training. Obviously, the math doesn't go away. Right, right. So we'll dive into a little bit on transformers maybe, and then we can back out and look at the whole problem again. So if I remember correctly, my knowledge is very limited, but transformer, somehow it takes in, it can take in an arbitrary number of words, and then it creates some embedded space
为了按照我想要的方式影响他们，并让他们采取正确的行动。所以你会发现，如果你真正剖析一下，它很快就会开始，我认为你会开始觉得，等一下，我必须把这更多地想象成我正在教导的人类的事情，而少把它想象成我正在训练的数学过程。显然，数学并没有消失。对，对。所以我们可能会稍微深入探讨一下 Transformer，然后我们可以退后一步，再次审视整个问题。因此，如果我没记错的话，我的知识非常有限，但是 Transformer，不知何故，它可以接收，它可以接收任意数量的词，然后它会创建一个某种嵌入空间
of that, that, that arbitrary, that variable length, you know, paragraph, I guess. And now then from that embedded, that's the encoder. And then from that embedded space, you have a decoder that can emit words and then, and then also emit emit transformation to the space. So imagine like you have this embedding that contains all these things that you want to say. And as you say those things, you move to different points of the embedding where now there's less to say. And eventually you emit some special token that says I'm done. Is that, I mean, do I kind of get that right? Or how do transformers work? Yeah. I mean, I think, you know, it's an area that's live, right? There's definitely, definitely a lot going on there. So I guess like what I would reference, I think for folks,
嗯，那个，那个任意的，那个可变长度的，你知道的，段落，我想。现在，从那个嵌入中，那是编码器。然后从那个嵌入空间中，你有一个解码器，它可以发出词，然后，并且还可以将转换发射到空间。所以想象一下，你拥有这个包含所有你想说的事情的嵌入。当你讲出那些事情时，你就会移动到嵌入中的不同点，现在那里要说的话变少了。最终，你会发出一个特殊的标记，说我完成了。是这样吗，我的意思是，我大致理解对了吗？或者 Transformer 是如何工作的？是的。我的意思是，我认为，你知道，这是一个活跃的领域，对吧？那里肯定，肯定有很多事情在发生。所以我想，我会参考的，我认为对大家来说，
like one thing that I think is important is this notion of attention, right? So one of the hard problems in language for a long time has been like, how well can a model One thing that I think is important is this notion of attention. One of the hard problems in language for a long time has been, how well can a model reference across a great degree of space between concepts? When you look at a problem, trying to think like a sequence problem, like a time series sequence, one of the longstanding problems in time series analysis is like, well, what if I have an effect like last January and now it affects this March or something, right? And that's a macroeconomic underlying effect. And so there's
比如我认为重要的一件事就是这种“注意力”的概念，对吧？所以很长一段时间以来，语言学中一个很难的问题一直是，一个模型能有多好——我认为重要的一件事就是这种“注意力”的概念。长期以来，语言学中一个很难的问题一直是，一个模型在跨越大面积的概念空间进行引用时能有多好？当你看着一个问题，试图像序列问题那样思考，比如时间序列序列，时间序列分析中长期存在的问题之一就是，嗯，如果我有一个像去年一月份那样的影响，现在它影响了今年三月份或类似的事情，该怎么办，对吧？这是一个宏观经济的潜在影响。所以有
been all this work in sort of hand curated feature building in those contexts, which these are sequence models as well. So they're fundamentally the, you know, kind of like mathematically the same type of object that you have when you analyze language. You know, I think there's a lot of bespoke techniques to do that in time series analysis and, you know, all the ARIMA models and just, they go just like tons and tons of work. I think the same thing was done for many years, you know, in a hand curated way when looking at language. And so I think one of the, one of the years in a hand-curated way when looking at language. And so I think one of the advances that's pretty important in this context is that we've begun to train these models and these transformer-based systems in a way that they can locate those long associations. And in a way that they can provide for us, this is kind of another way to talk to the model.
所有这些在这些背景下人工精心策划特征构建的工作，这也是序列模型。所以它们在根本上，你知道，在数学上和你分析语言时拥有的对象是同一种类型。你知道，我认为有很多定制的技术来在时间序列分析中做到这一点，你知道，所有的 ARIMA 模型以及，它们进行了大量的工作。我认为多年来在研究语言时，也以人工策划的方式做了同样的事情。因此，我认为在这个背景下非常重要的进展之一是，我们已经开始以一种能够定位这些长程关联的方式来训练这些模型和这些基于 Transformer 的系统。并且以一种能够为我们提供的方式，这也是与模型对话的另一种方式。
They can provide for us connections between them, right? You can ask, well, what other words in the sentence does this word relate to? And in an industrial context, that's super helpful because as a way of tuning and debugging and, you know, trying to improve systems, right, those sort of like co-reference patterns. I don't mean co-reference in the literal sense of co-reference of language, but these patterns of correlation to these patterns of mutual interest or mutual effect become ways to find, to go and kind of ferret out the misunderstandings that the models are having and try to improve them. Got it. Okay, cool. That makes sense. Yeah, I think I definitely have to get ramped up on it.
它们可以为我们提供它们之间的连接，对吧？你可以问，这个词与句子中的哪些其他词相关？在工业背景下，这超级有用，因为作为一种调整、调试和，你知道，试图改进系统的方式，对吧，那些类似共指的模式。我指的不是语言共指字面意义上的共指，而是这些与相互兴趣或相互影响模式的相关性模式，它们成为了寻找、去找出模型产生的误解并试图改进它们的方法。明白了。好的，酷。这说得通。是的，我想我绝对必须赶上进度。
My background's in reinforcement learning, and I saw a paper recently about someone using transformers to do sequential decision-making. And so transformers are kind of coming into like a battering ram, just coming into my field and so many other fields. And so transformers are kind of coming into like a battering ram, just coming into my field and so many other fields. And so I have to definitely, I have a to-do to get, to get ramped up on them. But, but yeah, I think that I've had seen the word attention a lot and yeah, maybe we'll, uh, well maybe we'll get you back on and we could do a whole show on transformers or we could get somehow get ramped up on that. Yeah, let's pivot to LivePerson. So tell us about LivePerson and what you all do and what kind of services or products you provide.
我的背景是强化学习，我最近看到了一篇论文，关于有人使用 Transformer 来做序列决策。所以 Transformer 就像一根攻城锤一样，刚刚进入我的领域以及许多其他领域。因此，Transformer 就像一根攻城锤一样，刚刚进入我的领域以及许多其他领域。所以我绝对必须，我有一个待办事项去赶上进度，去掌握它们。但是，但是是的，我看到过很多次“注意力”这个词，是的，也许我们，嗯，也许我们会请你再次做客，我们可以做一个关于 Transformer 的完整节目，或者我们可以设法掌握这个。好的，让我们把话题转向 LivePerson。给我们讲讲 LivePerson，你们是做什么的，以及你们提供什么样的服务或产品。
Yeah, so, all right, LivePerson, fundamentally what we're trying to do, we have some new things we're trying to do as well in terms of relating directly to customers, but the core business of LivePerson for the last 20 years or so has been about, you know, essentially making the connection between us, the people in the world and the brands we have to deal with or want to deal with a little bit better and making our lives a little easier because of it. And so that began back in the day with online chat, right? Which is sort of almost a dirty word now. And I think we
好的，那么，好吧，LivePerson，我们从根本上想要做的是，我们在直接联系客户方面也有一些新的尝试，但 LivePerson 过去 20 年左右的核心业务一直是，你知道，基本上在我们、世界各地的人们与我们必须打交道或想要打交道的品牌之间建立起更好的联系，并因此让我们的生活变得更轻松一点。所以这在当年是从在线聊天开始的，对吧？这现在几乎是一个脏字了。而且我认为我们
actually would say at LivePerson that we thought it was a kind of a dirtier word first, right? Not that online chat doesn't have useful applications and we still do a lot of online chat, but we don't see it as the future of like you know, like, Hey, I log into a website and I have a, like a sort of not persistent or like a liminal connection with a, with an agent on the other side. And I'm chatting with them for five minutes. And then, you know, if I break the connection and it's gone and I have to start again, we don't see that as like a model for like a real, for like a really good customer experience or a really good brand experience for that matter. But that is kind of nonetheless how the company was built because that model does have some
实际上会在 LivePerson 说，我们认为这首先是一个更脏的字眼，对吧？并不是说在线聊天没有有用的应用，我们仍然在做很多在线聊天，但我们并不认为它是未来的发展方向，你知道，比如，嘿，我登录一个网站，我有一个，类似于非持久的或介于两者之间的与另一端代理的连接。我和他们聊了五分钟。然后，你知道，如果我断开连接，它就消失了，我必须重新开始，我们不认为这是一种真正好的客户体验的模式，或者对于这方面的真正好的品牌体验的模式。但尽管如此，公司就是这样建立起来的，因为这种模型确实有一些
advantages over just the straight phone model that was what was there before. But as time has gone on, I guess it's about four years ago now, maybe five, LivePerson went early into a messaging context and what we call more asynchronous communication, right? So now you've got brands and consumers communicating through SMS messages, through WhatsApp, through Line in Japan, through whatever, right? There's a sort of umpteen messaging platforms out there. One of the things we do is we make sure
比以前那种纯电话模型更有优势的地方。但随着时间的推移，我想大约是四年前吧，也许五年前，LivePerson 很早就进入了消息传递的领域，也就是我们所说的更多异步通信，对吧？所以现在你有品牌和消费者通过短信、通过 WhatsApp、通过日本的 Line、通过各种渠道进行沟通，对吧？外面有无数的消息传递平台。我们所做的事情之一，就是确保
that you can hold a great conversation with your customers on these platforms. But where that obviously starts to lead, and it's really interesting when you look at the conversations people want to have and what it means to shop that way compared to what it means to shop in the web signature way that we shop today or, you know, the website context, I mean, the way that we shop today, it's fascinating, right? And one of the things, you know, the jokes I sometimes make is like one of my interview questions at Amazon was like, well, help me build a model about, you know, whether or not the shopper is about to leave the website or help me build a model as whether or not this is a gift shopper. How would you build
你能够在这些平台上与你的客户进行愉快的对话。但很明显，这开始走向何方，当你审视人们想要进行的对话，以及以这种方式购物意味着什么，与我们今天通过网页签名方式购物或，你知道，网站背景下的购物相比，这意味着什么，这真的很有趣，对吧？其中一件事，你知道，我有时开玩笑说，我在亚马逊的一个面试问题就像是，嗯，帮我建立一个模型，关于，你知道，这个购物者是否即将离开网站，或者帮我建立一个模型，关于这是否是一个礼品购物者。你会怎么建
that? Right. And these are things that people just tell you in a conversational context because they're trying to get help. So one of my favorites is a woman talking to a sporting goods company and she's like, hey, I late gift shopping for my 12 grandkids and my sixth grade grandkids. Can you please help me find some gifts for them? These Literally, the kinds of things that a company like an Amazon would be sifting through web search and web activity history to try and make an inference about are just things that people want to let you know that this is their problem. They want you to give them help in solving it. She was very interested in the fact that this service agent on the end of the line could next year reach out ahead of time with some proactive offers, all this stuff that can feel
立那个？对吧。而这些都是人们在对话语境中直接告诉你事情，因为他们在试图寻求帮助。所以其中一个我最喜欢的例子是一个女人与一家体育用品公司对话，她说，嘿，我为我的 12 个孙辈和我的六年级孙辈们迟来的送礼购物。请帮我找一些礼物给他们好吗？这些字面意思上，像亚马逊这样的公司需要通过筛选网络搜索和网络活动历史来试图进行推断的事情，恰恰就是人们想要让你知道这是他们的问题的事情。他们希望你给他们提供帮助来解决它。她对这条线另一端的这个服务代理明年可以提前主动提供一些主动优惠、所有这些感觉的事情非常感兴趣。
seedy if a company is doing it behind the scenes on a website, but feels very natural if you're the one telling the company, this is my problem and I'd like you to help me. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah. When I drink the Kool-Aid on this problem and I'd like you to help me. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah. So when I kind of drink the Kool-Aid on this problem and sometimes I drink the Kool-Aid, I feel like what we're building is a way to do a more open and transparent and a little bit better and warmer conversational experience for shopping, which takes you back to the world that we all used to live in kind of before the internet where most of shopping was like that. Yeah. I think that to your point, I mean, uh, I've, I've recently been buying all my clothes online since COVID. Um, you know,
如果一家公司在网站的幕后做这件事，会让人觉得鬼鬼祟祟，但如果你是那个告诉公司“这是我的问题，我希望你能帮我”的人，就会觉得非常自然。是的，这说得通。是的。当我被这个问题的理念洗脑（当我有时被这个理念洗脑时），我觉得我们正在构建的是一种为购物提供更公开、更透明、更好、更温暖的对话体验的方法，这把我们带回了我们大家以前生活过的互联网之前的世界，那时大多数购物都是那样的。是的。我认为说到点子上了，我的意思是，嗯，自从新冠疫情以来，我最近一直在网上买所有的衣服。嗯，你知道，
once you've narrowed down the size and, and, you know, almost everything comes in almost every size. So narrowing down the size doesn't really do anything. Well, you know, it's almost like, like, how do you sort of search for your aesthetic? It's really difficult. Yeah. But I think that, that if it was sequential, like maybe I would search for blue shirt and I would look at what came back and I would realize, okay, really what I need is a blue striped shirt. And, and somehow knowing that this person pivoted to blue striped shirt, that, that now it's like, okay, you have these two things and maybe you would show a Stripe shirt that's Navy because that Stripe part is really important. And so just, yeah, just handling that modality,
一旦你缩小了尺码的范围，而且，你知道，几乎每件衣服都有几乎所有的尺码。所以缩小尺码的范围其实起不到什么作用。好吧，你知道，这几乎就像是，你如何搜索你的美学？这真的很困难。是的，但我觉得，如果是按顺序的，也许我会搜索蓝衬衫，我会看看返回的结果，然后我会意识到，好吧，我真正需要的是一件蓝白条纹衬衫。而且，不知何故，知道这个人转向了蓝白条纹衬衫，现在就像是，好吧，你有了这两件东西，也许你会展示一件深蓝色的条纹衬衫，因为那个条纹部分真的很重要。所以，是的，处理这种模态，
I think is a conversation. And whether you're doing it through a search engine or you're doing it with text generation, I think that's something that has to be addressed. Well, and if you think about it, like what you really want to understand if you're in that conversation with someone and trying to help them buy a shirt is is something a little more fundamental about what they're doing.
我认为这是一场对话。无论你是通过搜索引擎来做，还是通过文本生成来做，我认为这是必须解决的问题。嗯，如果你仔细想想，如果你正在和某人进行那样的对话并试图帮他们买一件衬衫，你真正想要了解的是关于他们在做什么的更基础的事情。
Right. Like, are we are we in a situation here? I don't know how you shop, but like, you know, I might be in a situation where I've like I've already had three copies of this basic shirt. I'm trying to find it in a different color and I know it fits well. And I and I kind of just want to get moving and like go get myself a fourth one because I love these shirts. Like it's a pretty uncomplicated mission. And what I want in that situation is someone to show me, you know, all the different copies of that particular item. And then maybe, you know,
对吧。就像，我们，我们是不是处于这样一种情况？我不知道你是怎么购物的，但像，你知道，我可能处于这样一种情况，我已经有了这件基本款衬衫的三件复制品。我正试图找一件不同颜色的，我知道它很合身。而且我，我其实只是想继续前行，去给自己买第四件，因为我太喜欢这些衬衫了。这其实是一个相当简单的任务。在这种情况下，我想要的是有人向我展示，你知道，那个特定物品的所有不同复制品。然后也许，你知道，
I want a little back and forth on the style I'm looking for and I'm done. You know, or I may be like, have been like poking around the internet. I'm like, oh, you know, I need a little bit of a fashion change. Like, I feel like I'm kind of boring right now and I'm looking for new ideas.
我想要对我在寻找的风格进行一点来回的沟通，然后就完成了。你知道，或者我可能一直在互联网上到处闲逛。我想，哦，你知道，我需要一点时尚的改变。就像，我觉得我现在有点无聊，我在寻找新的创意。
And I, you know, I'm looking for a shirt that like, you know, maybe I wouldn't have worn before and I might need a little, like I might need a really different experience. Maybe I'm teaching seventh grade and I need a periodic table. That's somehow also like WWF. Right, right. I need this SmackDown, like I need to turn it over and then, you know, Macho Man Randy Savage can jump out of it or something. Yeah, like a hydrogen atom and just crush it. Yeah, exactly. So I think you want those missions. This is a lot of where the three-line for at least my career sort of matches between Amazon and Nike and live person. It's like, what are those missions and how do you define them? And I think the language context is obviously the best context to define them in. A lot of what we build is about allowing brands to sense that and to identify those missions from the language that those customers give them so they can be more helpful.
而且我，你知道，我在找一件衬衫，就像，你知道，也许我以前不会穿的，我可能需要一点，就像我可能需要一个完全不同的体验。也许我正在教七年级，我需要一个元素周期表，它不知何故也像世界摔角娱乐（WWF）一样。对，对。我需要这种 SmackDown（疯狂摔角）风格的，我需要把它翻过来，然后，你知道，“野人”兰迪·萨维奇可以从里面跳出来什么的。对，就像一个氢原子，然后把它压碎。对，完全正确。所以我想你想要这些任务。这很大程度上就是至少我的职业生涯中，亚马逊、耐克和 LivePerson 之间的共同点所在。就像，这些任务是什么，你如何定义它们？我认为语言语境显然是定义它们的最佳语境。我们构建的很多东西，都是为了让品牌能够从这些客户给他们的语言中感知和识别这些任务，这样它们就能提供更多的帮助。
And so when we talk about conversational AI, or at least the tools of conversational AI and how we use them at LivePerson, there's at least two big categories. One category is around, of course, helping brands build these systems so that they can have automated ways for customers to solve their problems so that it's easier and faster and better for everyone. And then the other side is like, okay, well, how do you... Are you set up to really listen to your customers? You know, do you know, for instance, that when, you know, your customer complains about having tried to call you having tried to reach on your website, and having tried to, you know, to text message with you, by the time they're at that point, they've got like an 80% chance that they're going to leave you. Because there's this canonical
因此，当我们谈论对话式 AI，或者至少是对话式 AI 的工具以及我们在 LivePerson 如何使用它们时，至少有两个大类别。一个类别当然是围绕着帮助品牌构建这些系统，以便他们拥有让客户解决问题的自动化方法，这样对每个人来说都更轻松、更快、更好。然后另一个方面是，好吧，那么，你如何……你准备好真正倾听你的客户了吗？你知道，例如，你知道当你的客户抱怨曾试图打电话给你、曾试图在你的网站上联系你、曾试图给你发短信时，当他们到了那个地步，他们有大约 80% 的几率会离开你。因为存在这样一个典型的问题，
problem that like, that just just frankly makes everybody mad. And so being able to listen to stuff like that at scale and understand that at scale so that you can provide a better customer experience, that's another sort of layer of the conversational AI offering that we think is really important for us and really important for brands. Because in the end,
这个问题，坦白说，会让所有人生气。因此，能够在大规模上倾听这样的事情并在大规模上理解它，以便你可以提供更好的客户体验，这是我们认为对我们非常重要、对品牌也非常重要的对话式 AI 产品的另一层。因为到头来，
consumers in America and other places now, we're pretty fickle beasts, right? Like we've been kind of trained by like the Amazons of the world and other companies that have pioneered in customer service, you know, to create like these really positive service experiences for us that they're really different than 30 years ago. Right. But now that's the norm. Like, and if you want to, you want to keep building your customer base, if you don't have a captive audience, if you're not like a cable company or something where like nobody can leave you, then you have to be great at this now. And you have to kind of blur that line between what are you, you know, how are you solving their problems? And then how does that translate into
现在美国的消费者和其他地方的消费者，我们都是相当反复无常的兽类，对吧？就像我们一直被亚马逊这样的世界和其他率先开展客户服务的公司所训练，你知道的，为我们创造了这些真正积极的服务体验，它们与 30 年前完全不同。对吧。但现在这成了常态。就像，如果你想，你想继续扩大你的客户群，如果你没有一个被俘获的受众，如果你不像有线电视公司那样没有人能离开你，那么你现在就必须在这方面做得非常出色。而且你必须模糊这条界限，介于你在，你知道，你如何解决他们的问题，以及这如何转化为
future growth between you and them and building that strong relationship? So, so we kind of build products on both sides of that, right? We build natural language understanding with both of those use cases in mind, for instance. It sounds like another part on the product side that I think would be really tricky would be knowing when to hand off to a real person. That seems like something that a lot of companies wouldn't know how to do. They would really rely on you for that. Yeah, that's right. And I think that's actually like a nook in a much bigger problem, which is, how do I understand how well the system is doing with my customers? How do I understand the quality of these conversations between the computer and the person? And there is not good tooling for that.
你和他们之间的未来增长并建立牢固的关系？所以，我们在这两个方面都构建了产品，对吧？例如，我们在构建自然语言理解时，心里就记住了这两个用例。听起来在产品端的另一个部分，我认为会非常棘手的是，知道何时该转交给真人。这似乎是很多公司都不知道该怎么做的事情。在这方面，他们会非常依赖你。是的，确实如此。我认为这实际上是一个更大问题中的一个小角落，也就是，我如何了解系统在我的客户身上做得怎么样？我如何了解计算机与人之间这些对话的质量？而这方面并没有好的工具。
This is one of these foundational areas where I think you just don't find anything good in the industry right now because it's one of these annoyingly hard problems. And it's kind of related to all the abstract stuff we've been talking about. When does a model know it's doing well? When does it not? And how deep an understanding and how introspective is that model in the first place? And the answer is typically not very. So you can't rely on the model to do it. You need to kind of build some of these separate systems to be able to see this. And some of that requires like really rolling up your sleeves and doing some dirty work and being like, what are like the top 10, you know, kind of like, what's the right way to describe like the top 10 kinds of problems that people face when they're trying to talk to automated systems and how they break down and
这是这些基础领域之一，我认为你在目前的行业中根本找不到任何好的工具，因为它是这些烦人的难题之一。这与我们一直在讨论的所有抽象东西都有关。模型什么时候知道自己做得好？什么时候不知道？模型首先具有多深的理解力以及多少反省能力？答案通常是不高。所以你不能依靠模型来做到这一点。你需要构建其中一些独立的系统来能够看到这一点。其中一些需要真正撸起袖子做一些脏活累活，比如，前 10 名是什么，你知道，就像，描述人们在试图与自动化系统对话时面临的前 10 种问题的正确方法是什么，它们是如何分解的，以及
how that customer experience goes wrong. So we spent a lot of time on that. We have products, you know, that that we're bringing to market right now. In fact, on measurement, you know, the this got this like the product has this pithy name of Max, right, which is the meaningful automated connection score, which is really about like, hey, how, how good or bad was your CX in, in these automated conversations? And like, where should you improve it? So, and it's important for two reasons, right? One, you need to know how well you're doing in order to have any sensible business strategy. And two, tuning and optimizing these AI systems is like really hard. I shouldn't say it's really hard. It's, it's a lot more of work and ongoing work
那个客户体验是如何出错的。所以我们在那上面花了很多时间。我们有产品，你知道，我们现在正把它们推向市场。事实上，在衡量标准方面，这个，这个产品有一个生动的名字叫 Max，对吧，也就是有意义的自动化连接得分（Meaningful Automated Connection Score），这其实是关于，嘿，你的 CX（客户体验）在这些自动化对话中究竟是好是坏？以及你究竟应该在哪里改进它？所以，它之所以重要有两个原因，对吧？第一，你需要知道自己做得有多好，才能拥有任何明智的商业战略。第二，调整和优化这些 AI 系统真的很难。我不应该说它真的很难。它比人们最初通常构思的
than people at first often conceptualize that it's going to be. Yeah, that's right. You got to think of it like if you're building a website, you don't build it on a Thursday, send it live, and then don't touch it for a year, right? Like you would never do that. But a lot of people think about conversation, oh, build the bot, I won't touch it, it's done.
工作要多得多，而且是持续不断的工作。是的，确实如此。你得这样想：如果你在构建一个网站，你不会在周四构建它，让它上线，然后一整年都不碰它，对吧？就像你永远不会那样做。但很多人对对话的看法是，哦，构建机器人，我不会碰它，它完成了。
But it's really, it's an ongoing process iteration and we need better tools to, in the same way we do website A-B testing, in the same way that we have a bunch of tagging and kind of infrastructure and software built up around learning what's working about your web presence and improving it. We need the same thing. You need the same things if you're going to learn about how to improve your conversational AI. And that's part of what this metric and the system is about is helping you quickly locate places where the conversations got wrong. Where did the bucket stuck in a circle, which drives us all crazy? Where did the NLU just totally barf and lose it and just completely break the customer trust? So our play in general has really been
但这确实是一个持续的迭代过程，我们需要更好的工具。就像我们做网站 A/B 测试一样，就像我们在围绕了解网站存在的价值并改进它构建了一堆标记以及基础设施和软件一样。我们需要同样的东西。如果你想学习如何改进你的对话式 AI，你也需要同样的东西。这就是这个指标和这个系统的一部分意义所在，它帮助你快速定位对话出错的地方。机器人卡在哪个环节了，这让我们所有人都抓狂？NLU 在哪里彻底崩溃并失去了理智，完全打破了客户的信任？所以我们总体的策略一直是
about quality. And one of the, one of the, obviously one of the most critical pieces of quality is like, do you really have good measurement? Do you have good understanding about what quality is? And do you have good pointers as to where quality went wrong? Yeah. I mean, this is a huge, huge problem. I think the people who, uh, if someone can even crack this, um, in a generic way, it generic way, it would move the entire industry a mile forward. Because I think we have all the same issues where it's just so hard to triage one of these situations. What we end up doing, you're probably doing something similar, is just coming up with so many metrics. For example, how many people are
关于质量。质量最关键的部分之一，显然是：你真的有好的衡量标准吗？你对什么是质量有好的理解吗？你有关于质量在哪里出错的好指引吗？是的。我的意思是，这是一个巨大、巨大的问题。我认为如果有人甚至能以一种通用的方式破解这个难题，以一种通用的方式，它将推动整个行业向前迈进一英里。因为我认为我们都有同样的问题，即对其中一种情况进行分诊是如此困难。我们最终做的，你可能也在做类似的事情，就是提出这么多的指标。例如，有多少人在
clicking on this, like what's the click rate? What's let's use Amazon example. What's the click rate? What's the conversion rate? How many people abandon the whole site? Um, how many people bounce all of that stuff. And then you have this other, you have this, this downstream problem where as soon as you define a metric, you create an incentive. And so people, you know, machine learning engineers at your company are going to try to drive that metric up. And so typically what happens is eventually something that's not being recorded will start to suffer, right? And so now you have to make a metric to track that. And so you end up like just adding more and more balls in the air. And it now you have to make a metric to track that. And so you end up like
点击这个，比如点击率是多少？让我们用亚马逊的例子。点击率是多少？转化率是多少？有多少人放弃了整个网站？嗯，多少人跳出了网站，诸如此类。然后你有另一个下游问题，一旦你定义了一个指标，你就创造了一个激励。所以人们，你公司的机器学习工程师会试图把这个指标推高。所以通常发生的事情是，最终没有被记录的东西将开始受损，对吧？所以现在你必须制定一个指标来跟踪这一点。所以你最终就像只是在空中增加越来越多的球。然后现在你必须制定一个指标来跟踪这一点。所以你最终就像
just adding more and more balls in the air. And it's because you're in this arms race with yourself. Right. And so, yeah, it's just so, so difficult to go through that process. It's a little bit like a metrics alphabet soup in some ways. One of the things we did to deal with that, the first thing we did before we started kind of working on this max project was we sat down and said like, well, we need to organize like this system. Like we need to organize the metrics somehow because, you know, people are doing exactly what you're saying. And like a conversation I probably had five times now is I'll go east before the pandemic, I would go physically to brands all the
只是在空中增加越来越多的球。这是因为你正在与自己进行这场军备竞赛。对吧。所以，是的，经历这个过程是如此、如此困难。在某些方面，这有点像指标字母汤。我们用来处理这个问题的做法之一，在我们开始着手这个 max 项目之前，我们做的第一件事就是坐下来讨论，嗯，我们需要组织这个系统。就像我们需要以某种方式组织指标一样，因为，你知道，人们正在做你刚才说的事情。我可能已经经历过五次这样的对话了，我会去东部——在疫情爆发之前，我会亲自去各个品牌，
time. And now I talk to them on the phone, but, but they, you. But I'd sit down and be like, OK, well, how's it going? They're like, oh, yeah, we built this bot. You know, it's whatever platform they built it on. And they're like, it's great. It's got an 80% containment rate. It's awesome. I'm like, that's great. What are you doing with the 80% extra capacity you now have in the human contact center?
一直去。现在我通过电话跟他们交谈，但是，但是我会坐下来问，好吧，进展如何？他们会说，哦，是的，我们构建了这个机器人。你知道，它是基于他们构建它的任何平台。他们会说，这太棒了。它有 80% 的阻留率（containment rate）。这太棒了。我说，那太棒了。你在人类联络中心里现在多出来的 80% 的额外容量在做什么？
What did you choose to do with all those people? You must have people at their desk with nothing to do, right. And the answer is never like, oh yeah, yeah. Like here's what we did with them. The answer is always like, well, no, no, actually volumes in the, in the human side have actually gone up or, or they, they basically stayed the same, but, but the bot's doing great. Right. And it's because it's fundamentally, because this concept of a containment is, is just a very broken way to think about whether or not the bot serves, serves the person in the way that it needed, you know, it solved the problem or not. So like I said, one of the things we did was we sat down, we said, well, let's organize the metrics into, you know, some conceptual framework that people
你对所有人选择了怎么处理？你一定有员工坐在他们的办公桌前无所事事，对吧。而答案从来都不是，哦，耶，耶。就像这是我们对他们做的事情。答案总是像，嗯，不，不，实际上人工这边的业务量实际上上升了，或者，或者它们基本上保持不变，但机器人做得很好。对吧。这从根本上是因为，因为阻留率这个概念，对于思考机器人是否以它需要的方式服务于人、它是否解决了问题来说，是一种非常破碎的思考方式。所以就像我说的，我们做的事情之一就是坐下来，我们说，好吧，让我们把指标组织到，你知道，人们可以使用的某种概念框架中，
can use so that they can see, because we're not going to get out of this. Like there's not going to be one magic number that does everything. This is actually a highly multivariate problem. There's lots of different ways to think about what good means. And people are adapting. As soon as you make a metric, someone will try to game it and then they'll cause another problem. Right, right. So you can't like kind of live on that one.
这样他们就能看到，因为我们摆脱不了这个。就像不会有一个神奇的数字能做到这一切。这实际上是一个高度多变量的问题。对于什么是“好”有很多不同的思考方式。而且人们在适应。一旦你制定了一个指标，就会有人试图利用它作弊，然后他们就会导致另一个问题。对，对。所以你不能只依赖那一个。
It's just, it's too unstable. Yep. So we built this framework, you know, we gave it the pithy name of the four E's, right? And there's an efficiency vector of metrics. There's a, you know, effectiveness in there's an efficiency vector of metrics. There's a, you know, effectiveness in solving the customer problem vector of metrics. There's an emotion, right? What's the customer's
它太不稳定了。是的。所以我们构建了这个框架，你知道，我们给它起了一个生动的名字叫“四个 E”（Four E's），对吧？有一个效率指标向量。有一个，你知道，解决客户问题的有效性指标向量。有一个，情感，对吧？客户的情感反应是什么？
emotional response. And now I'm going to like totally blank on the fourth E, which is going to make me super embarrassed. It'll come to me in a minute. Anyway, so we've split into these categories and under them, we put both sort of existing contact center metrics that people are used to, like repeat contact rate within an hour, within three hours, within a day. And then some of these newer metrics like, hey, what's the max CX on this? Or what's the sentiment of the customer as measured by these machine learning models? Now you can begin to give brands a sort of reasonable target to optimize for that makes conceptual sense to them. The fourth E by the way was effort, right? How much work did it take to solve this problem?
现在我可能会完全想不起第四个 E 是什么，这会让我超级尴尬。我一会儿就能想起来。无论如何，所以我们把它分成了这些类别，在它们下面，我们既放了人们习惯的现有联络中心指标，比如一小时内、三小时内、一天内的重复联系率。然后还有一些较新的指标，比如，嘿，这个上的 max CX 是什么？或者由这些机器学习模型测量的客户情感是什么？现在你可以开始给品牌一个合理的优化目标，这对他们来说在概念上是有意义的。顺便说一句，第四个 E 是努力程度（Effort），对吧？解决这个问题花了多少力气？
And that's really, these are like much more connected to things that we care about as customers. Like when I tried to contact you, did it work or not? That's effectiveness. Like how much of a pain and frustrating was it? That's emotion. How much work did I actually have to go through to do it? That's my effort, right? So those correlate, these concepts, I think, correlate a lot better to what a great CX is. So we spent a lot of time on that. And then that set up, again, like some of the max work and some of the analytics work that we've done subsequently as well. Very cool. Very cool. So what is something that makes, and I know with COVID with COVID we're all working from home. And so, and so everyone's, uh, job looks pretty much the same. There's, there's, there's kids running
这真的，这些与我们作为客户所关心的事物联系得更加紧密。就像当我试图联系你时，它起作用了吗？那是有效性。它有多痛苦和令人沮丧？那是情感。我究竟不得不经历多少工作来完成它？那是我的努力程度，对吧？所以这些相关联，这些概念，我认为与什么是伟大的客户体验（CX）关联得更好。所以我们在那上面花了很多时间。然后这就建立起来了，再次强调，就像一些 max 的工作和我们随后做的一些分析工作一样。非常酷。非常酷。那么，有什么事情让——我知道在新冠疫情期间，我们都在家办公。所以，所以每个人的工作看起来都差不多。到处都有
around and there's a dog and there's, you know, but like, but like before COVID or maybe projecting into the future, what about live person is really unique or you kind of walk into the office or maybe you talk to the folks and you feel like this is something I've really seen anywhere else. Yeah. You mean like in terms of being inside the company or in terms of what the product offers? It could be, I know this is, this is inside the company. So it could be, it could be, you know, everyone plays ping pong on Thursdays, or it could be something about the nature of the kind of, the kind of ethos that you've built, something like that. Yeah. Yeah. So for me, I mean, I don't know, you probably have to bring people on, you know, on the, like on the team to make sure I'm not lying to you, but I can tell you about
跑来跑去的小孩，还有狗，你知道的，但是，但是就像新冠疫情之前或者也许展望未来，LivePerson 有什么真正独特的，或者你走进办公室，或者也许你和员工交谈，你觉得这是我在其他任何地方都没有真正见过的东西。是的。你是说在公司内部而言，还是在产品提供的功能而言？这可能是，我知道这是在公司内部。所以它可能是，你知道，每个人都在星期四打乒乓球，或者它可能是关于你们建立的那种精神本质的东西，诸如此类。是的。是的。所以对我来说，我不知道，你可能得把人带进来，你知道，带进团队来确保我没有对你撒谎，但我可以告诉你
some of the things we strive to do and some of the things that I see is successful at. I don't think it's easy. I guess, let me talk about the science domain. Like, I don't think it's easy to have, to, to combine two critical concepts that are important for real success in like scientific research and product development. And those two concepts are one, like the truth seeking, you know, are you really satisfied with what you've done or could it be better, you know, or what's really wrong here, those kinds of questions. And then two, like a spirit of real collaboration and support. Right. So oftentimes, like when I was a physicist, right, like the way that physics solves this
我们努力做到的一些事情，以及我看到取得成功的一些事情。我认为这不容易。我想，让我谈谈科学领域。像，我认为要结合对科学研究和产品开发真正成功至关重要的两个概念并不容易。这两个概念一个是，求真精神，你知道，你真的对你所做的事情满意吗，或者它能更好吗，你知道，或者这里真正出了什么问题，诸如此类的问题。然后二是，真正的合作与支持的精神。对吧。所以通常情况下，就像当我是一名物理学家时，对吧，物理学解决这个
problem is by not solving it. They just let like they just go after option one. And, you know, it's it's it's not at all uncommon to for the chief like discourse between two physicists to begin with, like, you know, for somebody to start out with, well, that's great what you said, but let me tell you all the ways in which you are an idiot. Right. Like literally, you know, for somebody to start out with, well, that's great what you said, but let me tell you all the ways in which you are an idiot. Right. Like literally, you know, we have a term for that. We call that the intelligent jerk. Yeah.
问题的方法就是不解决它。他们只是让，他们只是追求选项一。而且，你知道，两个物理学家之间的主要对话以，你知道，以某人开始说“你说的很棒，但我来告诉你你在所有方面都是个白痴”的方式开始，这根本不算不常见。对吧。就像字面意义上的，你知道，以某人开始说“你说的很棒，但我来告诉你你在所有方面都是个白痴”的方式开始。对吧。就像字面意义上的，你知道，我们有一个词来形容那个。我们称之为“聪明混蛋”。是的。
It's a, it's a archetype, an anti hero of the, of the tech world. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And I mean, it's very common and like, there's a sense to it logically. Like if you don't have some of that disagreeableness, and I mean that like literally in the psychological sense, you know, you run into like too much conformity and you don't do great work, right? Like you can't actually do well without some degree of that. same impulse and understand how to express it in a way that is constructive, right, rather than destructive and like builds partnership rather than tearing it down. Those are special people.
这是一个原型，科技世界的反英雄。是的。是的。是的。我的意思是，这很常见，而且，从逻辑上讲它有一定道理。如果你没有那种好争辩的特质——我的意思是心理学意义上的那种——你会遇到太多的顺从，从而做不出伟大的工作，对吧？就像如果没有某种程度的那种冲动并理解如何以建设性而不是破坏性的方式表达它，并建立伙伴关系而不是拆台，你就无法真正做得很好。这些人都是特殊的人。
And we work very hard to, you know, to really staff ourselves with that combination of skills, like up and down the science org. And I'm pretty pleased with how we've done. I think, I think it's one of my, it's, it's without a doubt, my favorite place to go to work and, and do science work and learn about, you know, research that I've ever had. And I had good situations in Amazon, a good situation at Nike. I'm not saying they were bad, they were great, but this, I think we've done something special by prioritizing, you know, that combination. We have not hired great people that we felt like just weren't going to hit dimension two very well. Yep. Yeah. It's a really good, really good point. Cause the other thing too, is, um,
而且我们非常努力地，你知道，真正为自己配备那种技能组合，就像在整个科学组织中上下贯通一样。而且我对我们的表现相当满意。我认为，我认为这是我毫无疑问最喜欢去工作、去做科学工作以及了解我所经历过的研究的地方。我在亚马逊有过很好的环境，在耐克也有很好的环境。我并不是说它们不好，它们很棒，但这个，我认为我们通过优先考虑这种组合，做了一些特别的事情。我们没有聘用那些我们觉得可能无法很好地达到第二个维度的优秀人才。是的。是的。这是一个非常好的、非常好的点。因为另一件事也是，
people who are really good, you know, and have the right, you know, emotional quotient and, and, and, and have that ethic and, and, and have all of those, those pieces, they're going to grow really quickly. And people go quickly, you know, I don't know what data there is on this, but people who go quickly will maybe want to change teams because there's an opportunity somewhere else or change companies or something like that. But people who are in over their head or who don't have the right character, those tend to be the people who stay forever and then so it's like it's so difficult to i mean so much time needs to be spent to get spent to get that right because yeah otherwise you know you there could be whole years where there's there's problems that that that take a very long time to sort out yeah i think there's some dynamics like you're talking about that are
真正优秀的人，你知道，并且有正确的，你知道，情商，并且有那种道德规范，并且拥有所有这些，所有这些部分，他们会成长得非常快。而且人们成长得很快，你知道，我不知道这方面有什么数据，但成长快的人可能会想换团队，因为其他地方有机会，或者换公司之类的。但是那些力不从心或者没有正确品格的人，往往是那些永远留下来的人，所以这就好像太困难了——我的意思是需要花大量的时间来把这件事做好，因为，是的，否则，你知道，可能会有整整一年的时间存在需要很长时间才能解决的问题。是的，我认为存在一些像你所说的动态，
very real you know i felt like i think one know, one partial antidote to at least the first part, I don't have a good antidote to the second one, but I think one thing we're also really fortunate about at LivePerson is we have pretty amazing data and capabilities to work with, right? There's hundreds of millions of goal-oriented dialogues coming through the platform every day. Obviously, we use those thoughtfully, carefully, and respecting all the contractual arrangements we make. We don't use all those conversations the same way, but different brands have different expectations about how we use that data. But nonetheless, there's lots and
非常真实，你知道，我觉得，我认为对于至少第一部分，我没有针对第二部分的好的解药，但我认为我们在 LivePerson 也很幸运的一点是，我们拥有相当惊人的数据和能力可以使用，对吧？每天都有数以亿计的面向目标的对话流经平台。显然，我们深思熟虑、小心翼翼地使用这些数据，并尊重我们达成的所有合同安排。我们不会以相同的方式使用所有这些对话，但不同的品牌对我们如何使用该数据有不同的期望。尽管如此，还是有大量
lots of amazing conversations to work with. And there's also tens of thousands of people sitting on the platform who can inform conversational AI with their opinions and their expert opinions, right? All these agents sitting there able to give feedback to the systems and tell them when they're working well and when they're not. And so some of those tools, I think like fuel, you know, much more so than anything that I or the other managers on the team do every day, fuel like people coming and really kind of hunkering down with live person and doing, doing good work for a long time. So it's, it's been nice to experience that, but yeah, in general, I agree with your, your assessment of the dynamics. Like you get somebody in a, you know, who's struggling on
大量精彩的对话可以利用。而且平台上还有成千上万的人，他们可以用他们的意见和专业意见为对话式 AI 提供信息，对吧？所有这些坐在那里的代理都能够向系统提供反馈，并告诉系统它们什么时候工作得好，什么时候工作得不好。因此，其中一些工具，我认为就像燃料一样——比我和团队中的其他经理每天所做的任何事情都要多——推动着人们来到这里，真正与 LivePerson 紧密合作，并长期做好工作。所以体验到这一点很好，但是，是的，总的来说，我同意你对这种动态的评估。就像你让某人进入一个，你知道，正在苦苦挣扎的人
one of these two dimensions of work and it's hard for them to leave because it's like, there's a lot more risk for them. Yep. Yep. So, so for folks who are listening to this and, and completely enamored, they want to do conversational AI, they want to get into this field. Does LivePerson have any openings? And can you kind of break it down into, does LivePerson have internships? Do you have full-time positions? And if there are post-COVID, if there are geographic locations you want to focus on, what are those? Sure. So the first thing to say is we're hiring a lot. The company's grown. You go read our public record reports. We are a public company, so you can see how we're doing and we're growing rapidly.
工作中的这两个维度之一，他们很难离开，因为这就像是，对他们来说风险要大得多。是的。是的。所以，对于那些听了这个节目并且完全着迷的人，他们想要从事对话式人工智能，他们想进入这个领域。LivePerson 有空缺职位吗？你能详细说明一下 LivePerson 是否有实习机会吗？你们有全职职位吗？如果有，在疫情之后，如果你们有想要关注的地理位置，那些地方是哪里？当然。所以首先要说的是我们正在大量招聘。公司在发展。你去阅读我们的公开记录报告。我们是一家上市公司，所以你可以看到我们的表现，而且我们在快速增长。
So we have a lot to do. This year, I'm really trying to focus on building an exceptional scientific research team that's going to look farther afield in time, right? So we've typically had at LivePerson a strategy of, well, like we want to work on research, we want to work on science, but we want it to be in the context of being productizable in the near to medium term. So really not much more than six months out, we want to see this come to life in a way that impacts the product. And I think that was right for where we were and all the stuff we needed to build. There was a lot of obvious stuff to do, but now we're in a different place. And I think we want to be looking on one, two, three, four year timeframes for how some of this stuff turns into technology that we can use. And we want to go a little deeper with academic
所以我们有很多事情要做。今年，我真的在努力专注于建立一个杰出的科学研究团队，他们将在时间上看得更远，对吧？因此，我们通常在 LivePerson 有这样一种策略，就是，我们希望从事研究，我们希望从事科学工作，但我们希望它是在近期到中期可以产品化的背景下进行的。所以实际上不超过六个月，我们希望看到它以影响产品的方式实现。我认为这符合我们当时的情况以及我们需要构建的所有东西。有很多显而易见的事情要做，但现在我们处在不同的地方。而且我认为我们希望以一、两年、三、四年的时间框架来看待其中一些东西如何转化为我们可以使用的技术。而且我们希望与学术界进行更深入的合作
partnerships as well. So I'm staffing just a full team on research with kind of that mandate, looking for a lead for that who wants to come in and say, OK, I see this data you've got. I understand you guys have a basic dialogue problem you're trying to solve. And I want to go push science research in this direction in partnership with this, you know, academic institution over the next three, four years. And here's the agenda and is going to help drive that. And I mean, I have some ideas about where that should go, but I'm really looking for a very senior lead to come in and, you know, and take the reins on that. So we're actively recruiting there. And they, of course, will actively recruit for the team, you know, that works with them. But we have other jobs and other opportunities as well. LivePerson's an engineering company, you know, on my team, you know, I hire analysts as well. We do it like I run a lot of
伙伴关系也是如此。所以我正在为研究人员配备一个全职团队，带有这种使命，寻找一个负责人，他想进来并说，好吧，我看到了你们拥有的这些数据。我理解你们正在尝试解决一个基本的对话问题。我希望与这个学术机构合作，在未来三四年里推动这个方向的科学研究。这就是议程，并且将有助于推动这一进程。我的意思是，我对它应该走向何方有一些想法，但我确实在寻找一个非常资深的负责人进来，并且，接管这一切。所以我们正在那里积极招聘。当然，他们也会为与他们合作的团队积极招聘。但我们也有其他工作和其他机会。LivePerson 是一家工程公司，你知道，在我的团队里，我也雇佣分析师。我们这样做，就像我管理 LivePerson 的很多
the analytics products for live person. And we hire, of course, machine learning engineers. We hire people to build backend systems that are supporting all the model building and the model training and the model management. And, you know, we're doing a bunch of work of migrating pieces of the platform into the cloud. And so there's a lot of like real engineering work. So one vector that often works well is for if someone has a strong engineering background and they're interested in this space, right? There is a, you know, there's definitely work to do to become an expert
分析产品。当然，我们也会雇佣机器学习工程师。我们雇佣人员来构建支持所有模型构建、模型训练和模型管理后端系统，而且，你知道，我们正在做大量将平台部分迁移到云端的工作。所以有很多真正的工程工作。因此，一个通常运作良好的途径是，如果某人拥有很强的工程背景并且对这个领域感兴趣，对吧？肯定有工作要做，以成为该领域的专家
in the science and the field, but there are ways in, I think, to the, there's a lot of engineering work that provides like a boots on the ground, it kind of introduction to the technology stack and, and kind of gets you, and then you kind of get into the flow where we're now like, okay, you're coming to our Friday brown bags. You're talking to, you're working closely with scientists because you're building things that they're using. And so you're in conversations with them in a different way. It's a really live place to learn and grow. So, I mean, I would come, if I were someone with a strong engineering background who was looking to get in this field, I'd be looking for a way to do it with a role like that, rather than trying to
在科学和领域内，但我认为有切入的方法，有很多工程工作提供了实地考察式的介绍，让你了解技术栈，并且让你进入状态，我们现在觉得，好的，你来参加我们的周五棕色午餐会。你在跟科学家交谈，与他们紧密合作，因为你在构建他们使用的东西。所以你以一种不同的方式与他们进行对话。这是一个真正充满活力的学习和成长的地方。所以，我的意思是，如果我是一个有着强大工程背景并希望进入这个领域的人，我会寻找通过这样一个角色来做到这一点的方法，而不是试图
say, well, okay, I'm going to go to bootcamp for six weeks. I'm going to read a bunch of papers. I'm going to do some prototype chatbots, and then I'm going to be a bunch of papers. I'm going to do some, you know, prototype like chatbots. And then I'm going to be ready to do a research role tomorrow. I think, you know, maybe there are some people out there that are just like astoundingly fast learners and that will work. But I think for most of us regular humans, you know, you want to kind of, you want to find a way, like, I'm going to build this into my life for a couple of years. Yep.
说，好吧，我要去参加一个为期六周的训练营。我要阅读一堆论文。我要做一些原型的聊天机器人，然后我就会成为一堆论文。我要做一些，你知道，原型的聊天机器人。然后我明天就准备好担任研究角色了。我想，你知道，也许外面的确有一些人学习速度惊人得快，那样就行得通。但我认为对于我们大多数普通人来说，你知道，你会想要找到一种方法，比如，我要把这个融入我的生活中几年。是的。
And there's so much tribal knowledge, so much tribal knowledge that, I mean, that bootcamp doesn't exist where you're going to learn the tribal knowledge to be able to ace a research scientist interview. So yeah, I think your advice is spot on. Yeah, and I mean, in addition to acing the interview, even if you can, like, and you show up on day one, like, are you ready to do the job
而且有那么多的内部知识，那么多的内部知识，我的意思是，根本不存在这样一个训练营，让你学到内部知识去通过研究科学家的面试。所以是的，我认为你的建议非常准确。是的，我的意思是，除了通过面试，即使你可以，而且你在第一天出现，比如，你准备好做这项工作了吗
or are you setting yourself up to succeed? Right. Yep. Yep. Do you have internships? You have a lot of folks who are maybe in the middle of their college and they're looking for something over the summer, but then they're going to go back to college afterwards. Does that exist? Yeah. Yeah. In fact, I just, we just set up a meeting, I think for next week to sit down and talk about how we're approaching next year's crop of internships and what we'll do there. So, yeah, we will be doing internships and we do them all year. We have interns right now and, you know, for different disciplines and different times makes sense. Right. But there are a lot in the summer. And, you know, we've been focusing a little bit on some of the graduate students, you know, the last year or two.
还是你在为自己的成功做准备？对。是的。是的。你们有实习生吗？你们有很多正处于大学中期的人，他们在暑假期间寻找一些事情，但之后他们会回到大学。这种事情存在吗？是的。是的。事实上，我刚刚，我们刚刚安排了一个会议，我想是针对下周的，坐下来讨论我们如何处理明年的实习生招募以及我们在那里会做什么。所以，是的，我们会做实习，而且我们全年都在做。我们现在就有实习生，而且，你知道，不同的学科和不同的时间是有意义的。对吧。但夏天有很多。而且，你知道，过去一两年我们一直有点专注于一些研究生，你知道的。
So it's been mostly Ph.D. or master's degree students are coming in and doing internships. But I think we're going to change that this year and have a little bit more undergrad work to be done. The team's gotten a lot bigger. And one thing that means is that there's a wider variety of like types of work that needs doing. And I think we have some spots for a really good undergrad research project or two that, that look pretty interesting. Like I said, we're kind of still in the middle of figuring it out, but, but that's, that's basically where we're headed. And, and for me, I like to make sure that, Hey, if we're going to put an internship together, we want it to be something that's like a little risky, right? It's a great time to take a risk, but also something where we see like a legitimate chance for success.
所以进来做实习的大多是博士或硕士生。但我认为我们今年会改变这一点，并会有更多的本科生工作要做。团队变得大了很多。这意味着需要做的工作类型更加多样化。而且我认为我们有一两个非常好的本科生研究项目的名额，看起来挺有意思的。就像我说的，我们还在摸索中，但这就是我们大致要前进的方向。对我来说，我喜欢确保，嘿，如果我们要安排一个实习，我们希望它是一个有点冒险的项目，对吧？这是一个冒险的好时机，但也是一个我们看到真正成功机会的项目。
And like, it's going to, we're going to learn something either way and everyone's going to benefit from it. So, so I think we'll be in a position to do that with undergrads next year. We're definitely continuously in a position to do that with grad students, you know, that that's not going to change. So we'd love to hear from people who are interested in, you know, possibly joining us in that way. Cool. Excellent. And so folks want to check out LivePerson, you go to LivePerson.com
而且无论如何我们都会学到一些东西，每个人都会从中受益。所以，我认为明年我们会有能力与本科生一起做到这一点。我们绝对一直在不断地与研究生一起做到这一点，你知道，这不会改变。所以我们很乐意听到有兴趣以这种方式加入我们的人的声音。酷。太棒了。所以如果人们想了解 LivePerson，你可以去 LivePerson.com
and you can, you know, see what they're all about. And if you want to reach Joe, you could reach Joe at jbradleyatliveperson.com and you can shoot him. I'm sure you can shoot him a resume. He'll forward it to the right folks, or there's probably a place on LivePerson where there's like a careers page or something like that where you can. You can definitely apply online. You can definitely reach out to me too if you want to say hey. And I would love to hear from the audience here. As I mentioned before we got started, I think you guys do a pretty cool, pretty cool podcast here. I like how, how application focused it is. And yeah, it feels like it has a lot of, a lot of weight to it. So I'm sure your,
你可以了解他们的全部情况。如果你想联系乔，你可以通过 jbradleyatliveperson.com 联系乔，你可以给他发邮件。我确信你可以给他发一份简历。他会把它转发给合适的人，或者 LivePerson 上可能有一个地方，比如职业页面之类的，你可以在那里。你绝对可以在线申请。如果你想打个招呼，也绝对可以联系我。我很想听听这里的观众的意见。正如我在开始之前提到的，我认为你们在这里做一个非常酷的播客。我喜欢它有多么注重应用。是的，感觉它有很多分量。所以我确信你们的，
your listenership are all pretty cool people. Yeah, definitely. And they're, they're super motivated. We've actually connected a lot of interns to careers to at least to internships. And so, and, uh, and, and we're constantly getting emails. Uh, the show has been out for a while. So we're constantly getting emails from folks who have landed a full-time jobs or even been in them for several years. And it's, that's really special. So, so I feel, I feel good about, uh, I think there's, there's going to be people out there who are a great match for LivePerson. And now if you're listening to this, you're one of those matches, you know, check out the show notes, check out the website and get connected.
你的听众都是很酷的人。是的，绝对的。而且他们超级有动力。我们实际上已经把很多实习生和职业联系起来，至少是实习。所以，而且，我们不断收到电子邮件。节目已经播出一段时间了。所以我们经常收到那些找到全职工作甚至已经工作了好几年的朋友的电子邮件。这真的很特别。所以，我觉得，我觉得很好，我认为会有很多人非常适合 LivePerson。现在如果你在听这个，你就是那些合适的人选之一，你知道，查看节目笔记，查看网站并建立联系。
It sounds really, oh, actually, so we didn't cover location. So where is LivePerson based? Yeah, we're a distributed company now. We took, I mean, it's evolving. Like I think a lot of companies are. But when the pandemic started, we wanted to give certainty to everyone early on. And so, you know, we said, hey, if you want to move where you want to move, go move, right? Like as long as you can do your job, right? As long as it doesn't impact your work, you know, we were pretty open. And we're
听起来真的很，哦，事实上，我们没有讨论地点。所以 LivePerson 总部在哪里？是的，我们现在是一家分布式公司。我们采取了，我的意思是，它在不断发展。就像很多公司一样。但当大流行开始时，我们想尽早给每个人确定性。所以，你知道，我们说，嘿，如果你想搬到你想搬的地方去，那就搬吧，对吧？只要你能做好你的工作，对吧？只要它不影响你的工作，你知道，我们相当开放。而且我们
not sort of demanding people be ready for a mass return or anything like that, because we wanted people to live their lives. You know, now that we're coming out of the pandemic, I think we're not sort of demanding people be ready for a mass return or anything like that, because we wanted people to live their lives. You know, now that we're coming out of the pandemic, I think we're hopefully coming out, I guess we're resurging a little bit. But as we sort of take steps out, we are beginning to open physical offices again. We have an office open in Seattle here that I've been to, you know, we do COVID testing either the morning before you come in, or you go do it at the office before you come in. We're obviously following all the policies and protocols that are local to the areas, and we have our own sort of standards on top of that. So I think we will be coming back more and more physically.
并不要求人们准备大规模回归或诸如此类的事情，因为我们希望人们过自己的生活。你知道，现在我们正在走出大流行，我认为我们并没有要求人们准备大规模回归或诸如此类的事情，因为我们希望人们过自己的生活。你知道，现在我们正在走出大流行，我想我们有望走出来，我想我们正在复苏一点。但随着我们迈出步伐，我们又开始开设实体办公室了。我们在这里有一个在西雅图的办公室，我去过，你知道，我们在你进来前的早上做新冠检测，或者你进来前去办公室做检测。我们显然遵循当地的所有政策和协议，在此之上我们有自己的标准。所以我想我们会越来越多的回到实体办公室。
We're probably going to maintain a high degree of flexibility about where people work and how that comes to life. We have some policies and standards around how to manage the pay scales and things that you have to do from a corporate sense for the economics to make sense. But I think we've done that in a fair way and I think we're open-minded, and particularly when it comes to great science professionals and researchers and folks with a lot of machine learning engineering expertise and those people that people that are, you know, really like really doing great in these, in these very hot fields. Like these are the kinds of people we want to be really flexible with. Like the most important thing is for you to come and work with us and for us to get some good work done
我们可能会在人们在哪里工作以及如何实现这一点上保持高度的灵活性。我们在如何管理薪资标准以及从公司意义上必须做的事情以使经济学合理方面有一些政策和标准。但我认为我们以一种公平的方式做到了这一点，而且我认为我们思想开放，特别是当涉及到优秀的科学专业人士和研究人员以及拥有丰富机器学习工程专业知识的人以及那些真正擅长这些非常热门领域的人。这些就是我们想要非常灵活地对待的人。最重要的是你来和我们一起工作，让我们一起把工作做好
together. And the exact details about the location and all that are pretty secondary. Yep. Yep. Totally makes sense. Yeah. I think it's consistent with where everyone's at and, uh, I'm hoping they come up with some nice whiteboarding tool. I mean, that is really what as scientists, this is the thing we need is some, some way to whiteboard together. Yeah. We're looking at that right now. We've got a couple of options that I want to get put in the office and try out to see how they work. I don't know if they're any good yet or not. And we haven't really tried out the tech, but, but I kind of agree. Like I'd love to be sitting here and like have a whiteboard here that I can
至于地点的具体细节等等都是次要的。对。对。完全说得通。是的。我认为这符合大家的现状，我希望他们能想出一些好的白板工具。我的意思是，这确实是我们作为科学家所需要的，某种可以一起写白板的方式。是的，我们现在正在关注这一点。我们有几个选项，我想把它放到办公室里试用一下，看看它们效果如何。我还不知道它们是否好用。我们还没有真正试用过这项技术，但我有点赞同。就像我很乐意坐在这里，这里有一个白板，我可以
write on. And that like the writing of my, you know, my partner on the other end of the communication like appears and it's almost as if they were here. Like somebody solves that there'll be billionaires overnight. Yeah. I wonder if, you know, in general the VR headset is never going to be so convenient that I would wear it all day.
写下来。并且我（在通讯另一端的）搭档的字迹也会显现出来，就好像他们就在这里一样。如果有人能解决这个问题，他们一夜之间就会成为亿万富翁。是的。我在想，你知道，通常情况下，VR 头显永远不会方便到让我整天戴着它。
But I wonder if maybe that's, everyone keeps talking about the metaverse. I have no idea what the metaverse is. I'm assuming it's connected to VR, but that might be something where we could go into VR for an hour and then there could be some holodeck-like thing and then somehow at the end,
但我想也许那就是，每个人都在谈论元宇宙。我不知道元宇宙是什么。我假设它与 VR 有关，但这可能是我们可以进入 VR 一小时然后可能会有一些类似全息甲板的东西，然后不知何故在最后，
it would accumulate a whole bunch of notes. Yeah, yeah yeah yeah yeah i think it'll be interesting to see how we solve these problems they're they're much bigger problems now or more important problems now they were a couple years ago yeah i wonder about vr2 i i guess the metaverse is the what the old neil stevenson reference from snow crash or something which is oh that's right oh it's been so long i think i had to read that in high school it's been a long time since i should i should give it a reread it's one of the only sci-fi books i know of that where the three ring binder appears uh in a starring role at least for the first part of it yeah that's right it's been a while though yeah that's where i think they were
它会积累一堆笔记。对，对，对，对，对，我认为看看我们如何解决这些问题会很有趣，它们现在是更大问题或更重要的问题，比几年前更重要，是的，我也在想 VR2，我猜元宇宙是尼尔·斯蒂芬森对《雪崩》的旧引用什么的，哦，对了，哦，时间太久了，我想我不得不在高中时读那本书，距离我应该重读它已经很久了，这是我所知道的唯一一本三环活页夹在其中扮演主演角色的科幻书，至少在它的前半部分是这样，是的，没错，不过已经很久了，是的，那就是我认为他们能够
able to they someone i think it's like a murder mystery or something, or so at some point I think somebody dies. Yeah. They're somehow killed in VR. I mean, it's, it's, I have very, very,
做到的地方，有人，我认为这就像一个谋杀悬疑或其他什么，或者在某些时候我认为有人死了。是的。他们不知何故在 VR 中被杀了。我的意思是，我有非常，非常，
uh, not lucid at all memories of, of that book. Language is a virus, right? Is this whole concept he's exploring. And I think there's this capability to like, you can,
完全不清晰的关于那本书的记忆。语言是一种病毒，对吧？这是他正在探索的整个概念。我认为有这样一种能力，你可以，
you can show people information and it infects them and gets them sick. If you show it to them in the metaverse or whatever, it's been a while for me too, but I think, I think it's something like that. Yeah. Yeah. We should make that book of the show next time. We need to read it again. Yeah. Yeah. That'd be fun. You guys ever want to do a Stevenson fest or something? He's I'll be, I'd be happy to come back.
你可以向人们展示信息，它会感染他们并让他们生病。如果你在元宇宙中或其他地方展示给他们看，对我来说也很久以前了，但我认为，我认为大致是这样的。是的。是的。我们下次应该把那本书作为节目的主题。我们需要再读一遍。是的。是的。那会很有趣。你们有没有想过举办一个斯蒂芬森节什么的？他，我很乐意回来。
Oh, cool. All right. We might take you up on that. Cool. Joe, thank you so much i know we're over time by by a lot but i really appreciate you spending the extra time and and chatting with us it's been absolutely amazing and it's been it's been a real pleasure thank you so much yeah the feelings mutual is a super fun conversation thank you so much for giving the opportunity to come on and chat with you guys very much appreciate it and i love like the depth and the quality of the discussion. So thank you so much for facilitating that. Cool. And thanks for everyone
哦，酷。好的。我们可能会接受你的邀请。酷。乔，非常感谢，我知道我们超时了很多，但我真的很感谢你花额外的时间和我们聊天，这绝对太棒了，这真的是一种荣幸，非常感谢。是的，彼此彼此，这是一次超级有趣的对话，非常感谢给我机会来和你们聊天，非常感谢，我喜欢讨论的深度和质量。所以非常感谢你们促成这一点。酷。也谢谢大家
out there. I think you continue to support us on Patreon and on Audible and we really appreciate that. I've been trying to post a bit more on Twitter. In the past, I've mainly used Twitter to send show notes, but I'm trying to put some more content on there. If I see something that I think is pretty cool and related to coding and tech, I've been trying to share more content there. So follow us on Twitter, follow us on all the other ones as well,
在外面。我想你们继续在 Patreon 和 Audible 上支持我们，我们真的很感激。我一直在试图在 Twitter 上多发一点。过去，我主要用 Twitter 发送节目笔记，但我正试图在上面放更多内容。如果我看到我认为非常酷且与编程和技术相关的东西，我一直试图在那里分享更多内容。所以关注我们的 Twitter，也关注所有其他平台，
LinkedIn and Facebook. Any of those, we'll definitely be posting the show notes there every time as they come out. And subscribe. definitely we'll definitely be posting the show notes there every time as they come out and uh and subscribe you know we can if we're not on a streaming platform at this point let us know i think enough people have let us know about enough platforms that were on all of them but there's there's new ones coming out all the time so definitely keep us up to date uh keep us honest if there's something we're not on and we'll catch everyone in two weeks thank you so much
领英和脸书。无论哪一个，每当节目笔记出来时，我们肯定会把它们贴在那里。还有订阅。绝对的，每当节目笔记出来时，我们肯定会把它们贴在那里，而且，如果我们现在不在某个流媒体平台上，请让我们知道。我想足够多的人已经告诉我们关于足够多的平台，我们已经在所有这些平台上了，但一直有新的平台出来，所以一定要让我们了解最新情况，如果有我们不在的平台，请提醒我们，我们会在两周后与大家见面，非常感谢
music by eric barnwell programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons know it. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
音乐由埃里克·巴恩韦尔提供，编程脱口秀由知识共享分发。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。